Bin ich am Start.
Ich muss noch kurz alles einschalten hier.
Und nix angemacht.
Boah.
Zehn Minuten oder so bin ich aufgestanden.
Einfach Rechte angemacht.
Streamtitel geändert, Stream angemacht.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal meinen Vorschau-Rechner hier anmachen,
dass ich Chat und sowas gescheit sehe, wenn ich irgendwas klicke.
Moin.
Und dann...
Mir läuft die Nase.
Und...
Dann muss ich noch die Linienkiste anmachen und alles.
Das dauert jetzt noch zwei, drei Minuten.
Du bist schon seit 6 Uhr wach.
Wie kommt's?
Hast du Nachtschicht oder irgendwas gehabt?
Oder einfach nur so.
Es gibt ja auch mal Tage, da
ist man einfach schon früher wach.
So.
Ich bin echt froh,
dass bei mir das mit dem Pennen
wieder gut funktioniert, jetzt schon eine ganze Weile.
Wollte ich sagen,
nicht schlafen können ist wirklich scheiße.
Suckt, sozusagen.
Massive.
Suckt das.
So.
Ah, hier will er Chrome aktualisieren.
Oder besser gesagt Chromium aktualisieren.
Soll er mal machen.
Äh, ja.
Windows.
Hallo?
Okay.
Windows?
Was ist los?
Okay, was auch immer
mein Windows hier gerade auf dem Vorschau-Rechner
treibt. Okay, jetzt.
Jetzt. Das hat einfach
gehängt.
hing.
Gehungen.
Okay, top.
Also, Chrome lädt jetzt
automatisch ein 5 GB AI-Modell.
Ja, das habe ich schon gelesen.
Letzte Woche auf irgendeiner Newsseite.
Und dass der Wal tot ist,
habe ich auch gelesen.
Leute, mir geht dieser Wal sonst...
Mich interessiert das so null,
was der Wal macht.
Habe ich das letzte Mal ja schon gesagt.
Diese ganze Aufregung um den Wal, Mann.
Ich hab das auch nicht verfolgt
Man hat es aber trotzdem mitgekriegt
Du konntest dich ja gar nicht wehren
Zwischenzeitlich haben sie ja gesagt
Sie müssen den Ball sprengen oder irgendwas
So, Moment, Moment, Moment
Nicht die VM starten, Blödsinn
Desktop starten
Linux Mini PC starten
Fullscreen
anmachen,
das Satur umstöpseln.
Ja, normalerweise mache ich das Setup
immer hier alle schon, bevor ich den Stream anmache.
Aber ich bin eh schon ein bisschen spät.
Habt ihr mitgekriegt?
Bitlocker
ist
gehacksort.
Geponed, wie man so schön sagt.
Ich hab mir noch nicht die Details
angeguckt. Ich hab nur gesehen, dass es da was gibt.
Wir können uns gleich ein Video zu angucken.
Und anscheinend, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe, warum man das verwenden sollte, das weiß ich auch nicht.
Aber es gibt genug Leute, die das verwenden.
Soweit ich gelesen habe, können damit Disks unlockt werden, ohne dass du das Passwort brauchst.
Was irgendwie dafür spricht, dass die Verschlüsselung nicht richtig ist.
Weil normalerweise bei ordentlicher Verschlüsselung und sagen wir mal auch halbwegs ordentlicher Implementierung dieser Verschlüsselung ist Passwort weg, Daten weg.
Muss ja auch so sein, sonst wäre es ja komplett sinnlos.
Aber wer weiß, was Microsoft da wieder getrieben hat.
Vielleicht, ja, vielleicht wurde das NSA-Bag doch gefunden.
Es gibt eine neue.
Hab ich gestern Abend auch gelesen, ja.
Hat gestern Abend jemand im Teams-Chat bei uns auf der Arbeit gepostet.
Ich habe es mir aber ehrlich gesagt nicht näher angeguckt.
Ich habe nur gesehen, dass es mittlerweile
einen Heise-Artikel
anscheinend dazu gibt.
Müssen wir mal kurz schauen.
Exchange.
Hier.
Lokale Nutzer können fremde Daten lesen.
Also, im Prinzip wieder irgendwas.
Können wir mal kurz lesen, was da
angesagt ist.
Die Sicherheitslücke ist seit Jahren bekannt.
Behoben wurde sie erst am Donnerstag.
Nur Stunden später gibt es einen Export, der derweil rüstet.
Okay, warum ist...
Aber wenn die Sicherheitslücke seit Jahren bekannt ist...
Es ist die vierte Sicherheitslücke
innerhalb weniger Tage...
Es ist die vierte Sicherheitslücke innerhalb weniger Tage.
Die Nierungsrutsche hat eine Ausweitung...
Sicherheitsforscher mit dem Namen SICK veröffentlichte mir Beispiele, die eine Lücke in der Speicherverwaltung des Lidungskollegs um eine Wettlaufsituation ergeben.
Das Beispiel der POC mit dem wohl stärksten ist SSH Keysign Pwn, das den SSH Private Key der Maschine ausliest.
Okay, Sicherheitslücken verstecken sich, bla bla bla bla, P-Trace.
Die Funktion P-Trace May Access schlägt bei Prozessen, die gerade beendet werden, auf eine zu offene Art fehl.
Das ist doch ganz weirdchampig übersetzt, oder? Was wollen die mir damit überhaupt sagen?
fail open
Okay
Gewinnt der Gewinnt der exploit eine race condition kann er trotz fehlerberechtigungen teil lesen die von dem sterbenden prozess
zuvor geöffnet worden waren aha gefunden hatte den fehler das sicherheitsunternehmen quali
Behoben wurde er von linux verwalter torwald am späten donnerstag nachmittag hat er selbst selbst
gepatcht
nur wenig später wurde kurzanalyse eine sve kennung hat sicherheit bislang nicht
bereits vor mehreren jahren war der fehler dem google sicherheitsexperten
jan horn aufgefallen der damals einen vorschlag zur bewegung gemacht hat
umgesetzt wurde aha aha da ist nicht wirklich neu ist noch mal
neu aufgeploppt oder so.
Er habe nun einen großen Knopf
auf dem Schreibtisch, um die Veröffentlichung
einer neuen Kernel-Version auszulösen.
Ob das jetzt einen Unterschied macht?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ob der jetzt auf seiner Tastatur was drückt
oder einen großen Knopf drückt,
macht doch keinen Unterschied.
Tatsächlich eine Ausführung.
Die großen und kleineren Linux-Distributoren werden den Fehler nun in...
Ja, okay.
Bis dahin können Admins mittels des Kommandos...
P-Trace...
Also Echo 3 nach P-Trace-Scope kann man das wohl deaktivieren.
Aha.
Okay, wenn in den Kommentaren steht, mit Windows wäre das nicht passiert oder irgendwie so typisches Heiseblödsinn.
Anscheinend nicht.
Okay, hätte mich aber nicht gewundert.
Okay, ja dann schauen wir doch mal, wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
Nicht, dass ich hier gepetraced werde.
was egal ist bei meinem Rechner,
ich benutze aber egal.
Wir machen mal ein Update.
Mal gucken, ob Arch, by the way,
beziehungsweise in dem Fall CacheOS,
schon die neueste Kernel-Version hat.
Seht ihr hier irgendwas?
Da ist ja irgendwas mit Linux.
Hier Cache, Cache,
ne.
Bin ich blind, Leute?
Kernel-Stelz.
Das ist bestimmt da drin.
Ich sehe es bloß nicht.
Egal, wir installieren jetzt die Updates.
Gucken wir mal, ob es bei Jetbrains neue Updates gibt.
Reboot gibt es dann.
Die Katze schaut auch zu.
Exzellent.
Hört sie auch zu?
Ich hoffe, sie hat jetzt ein bisschen blöd geguckt.
Ja, meine, also es ist ja nicht meine, meine, die immer zum Essen vorbeikommt, war heute Morgen um 7.30 Uhr wieder da, aber da habe ich noch gepennt.
Moin Max, schon länger nicht hier gewesen.
Hast du schon Glasfaser?
Ne, bei uns ist auch irgendwie nichts geplant.
Ich vermute, also das ist jetzt reingeraten, der Grund, warum hier nicht ausgebaut wird.
Die haben vor ein paar Jahren, also was weiß ich, es ist schon wirklich lange her, also keine Ahnung, 5, 6 Jahre oder so,
haben die damals VDSL, oder vielleicht ist es auch 8 Jahre, keine Ahnung, haben die damals VDSL ausgebaut und man kriegt da mittlerweile auch Gigabit von Vodafone.
So, und ich habe die Vermutung, dass das damals mit irgendwelchen Fördergeldern oder so vielleicht ausgebaut, das ist jetzt wirklich Kekalu, ja.
Ich habe die Vermutung, dass das damals vielleicht mit Fördergeldern ausgebaut wurde und es gibt ja so eine komische Regelung.
Ach, guck mal hier. Neuer Kernel.
Es gibt ja so eine komische Regelung.
Oder gab es. Ich weiß nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Dass wenn in einer Region mit Fördergeldern mal was ausgebaut wurde,
so und so viele Jahre danach nicht wieder mit Fördergeldern was ausgebaut werden darf.
Und vielleicht...
Keck Alu...
...legt das daran, dass sie deswegen bei mir nicht ausbauen.
Bist du noch bei... Ja, gut. Ja.
bin ich gibt ja keine andere variante hier ich habe auch noch nicht geupgradet auf gigabit ich
habe noch 400 down und 40 ab oder sowas oder 500 50 ab weiß es gar nicht ich glaube oder
auch keine ahnung gemacht auch kein großer unterschied war das mal leute ich war mal
Ich mach mal kurz einen Speedtest auf dem zweiten Monitor.
Wollen wir schon kurz...
Jetzt hier alle ablehnen.
Speedtest.
Also, ja, 400.
Naja, ein bisschen mehr ist es.
410.
415.
Ja
Den Upload-Test mache ich jetzt nicht
415, down
Den Upload-Test mache ich jetzt nicht, weil dann garantiert der Stream ruckelt
Ja, das muss man Vodafone zugute halten
Das funktioniert ganz gut
Leider haben die manchmal
Wechseln die wieder in ihren Shit-Modus
Und restarten
random den Router neu am Tag
oder es droppt irgendwie der Sync
oder der Upload
zu Twitch ist laggy as fuck,
aber das kommt in letzter Zeit
ausgesprochen selten vor.
Also das Shitvodafone
Emote brauchen wir gar nicht mehr so oft.
Der Stream hat ein und gefangen.
Ja gut, das kann schon sein.
Da wird ja die Leitung komplett dicht gemacht,
dass der stream dann ruckelt das ergibt ja irgendwie schon sinn so lasst mal kurz checken
was habe ich denn für die kölner version ich habe kölner linux cash ios
nennen in den linux cash ios lts habe ich ein lts können laufen leute
Gab es nicht ein Kernel
Kernel
Oder war das bei Manjaro
CashUS
Doch CashUS Kernel Manager
Ne
Ich hab 7081 installiert
7081 ist doch das
Was Heise hier geschrieben hatte
Wo die ganze
Geschichte gefixt ist oder
Ich mein wie gesagt bei meiner lokalen Kiste
wo nur ich Zugriff drauf habe, ist das wahrscheinlich
eh
jetzt nicht so wichtig. Ja, okay.
7.08. Wisst ihr?
Pleaning Edge Distro schlägt zu.
Direkt gepatcht.
So.
Dann gucken wir mal, was Jetbrain Updates
machen. Die wurden auch alle installiert.
Dann machen wir noch
Arch User Repo Updates.
Chaterino wird geupdatet.
Exquisite.
Kann die Fritzbox den Restart
nicht ignorieren.
Ich habe keine, also ja, ich habe eine Fritzbox, aber ich benutze die Fritzbox nicht zum Einwählen bei Vodafone.
Bei Vodafone habe ich immer noch das ganz normale Vodafone Modem davor.
Und das rebootet halt manchmal.
Und manchmal droppt es auch irgendwie den Sync.
Auch wenn ich nicht weiß, ob man es Sync nennt bei Kabel.
Stills.
So, wir haben alles geupdatet.
Dann würde ich sagen, es wird Zeit für...
Reboot.
Und wer sich jetzt fragt, warum dieses Kommando hier funktioniert,
ich habe ein High-IQ-Bash-Alias dafür,
dass beliebig viele R's beim Reboot funktionieren.
Die wichtigen Sachen sind halt einfach bei mir in der BASHA-C drin.
Du würdest dir keine Hardware von denen ins Haus stellen. Warum?
Ich meine, das Ding hängt...
...vor allem davor kommt nirgends wohin, außer an...
...nur nicht mal an den Gateway, also nur nicht mal an das interne Gateway dran.
Ne, ne, ne, ne
Einfaches R will ich nicht
Ich will ja Reboot ausschreiben mit möglichst vielen R's
Alias R für Reboot wäre ja easy
Das Problem dabei wäre wahrscheinlich
Dass ich total oft aus Versehen R eingebe
Und dann rebooten würde
So
Exzellent.
Ich hoffe, meine Nase hat gleich aufzulaufen.
Das ist ein wenig nervig.
Um nicht zu sagen,
das suckt.
So.
Dann Firefox.
Ich will Firefox starten und nicht dieses komische, was auch immer das hier ist.
Okay, klicke ich einfach hier oben drauf.
Und jetzt will ich...
Ne.
Gut.
Ich zeige euch das jetzt mal, weil ich das so nice finde, wie ich das zusammengewurschtelt habe.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist der Part der ZSHRC, der dafür sorgt, dass man beliebig viele R's vor dem Reboot eingeben kann.
Ist das nicht...
nicht easy lesbar ich verstehe ich verstehe selber nicht mehr was es macht es ist okay
es ist eine schleife von 1 bis 100 so viel erkenne ich schon mal so und dann legt es
einen Alias an. Und zwar
einen Alias
mit
Eier. Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Der ersetzt
Okay, der macht hier
ganz viele
Nullen. Der macht quasi
so viele Nullen, äh
so viele
ich habe keine Ahnung
so viel mal S glaube ich, oder?
So viel mal S hintereinander
wie
hier in dem jeweiligen Schleifendurchlauf
drin steht, speichert das
in MyString
und dann
replaced es den Inhalt
von MyString
mit der gleichen Anzahl von
R's
ist das nicht eigentlich voll durch die Brust ins Auge?
und dann E-Boot hintendran.
Und das wird gealiast zu
Reboot. Also es wird
1 bis 100 erst gealiast.
Alter, das ist ja super eklig.
Ich verstehe
heute schon gar nicht mehr genau, wie es funktioniert. Ich hoffe, ich habe es
damals verstanden, wo ich das gemacht habe.
So, jetzt haben wir geupdatet.
Warum, warum, warum?
Aha, UpdateDB
wird
geupdatet.
Warum RSS? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Weil ich mir das damals so mit Stack Overflow zusammengewurschtelt habe.
Ich habe danach, weil ich das fertig gebastelt habe, tatsächlich auch mal die KI gefragt.
Könnte man das schöner machen?
Da war ganz viel Mist dabei.
Aber ein paar Sachen, die tatsächlich deutlich schöner und besser lesbar waren.
Aber dann habe ich mir gedacht, ey, weißt du was?
Warum durch irgendwas von KI ersetzen, wenn man auch was hässlich selbstgebautes drin stehen lassen kann?
Was?
You must agree to the YouTube Terms of Service to view this embedded.
Open the FFZ Control Center.
Okay.
Terms.
YouTube.
Yes
Excellent
Und jetzt kann ich mir die Vorschau angucken
C++ Dokument
Oh ne
Das kann ich mir dann angucken
Da würde ich wieder die ganze Zeit
am Flamen, wenn ich mir eine C++
Dokumentation angucke
Mich würde ja mal interessieren, ob man da vielleicht
auch sieht, was das
C++ Gremium so treibt
die ganze Zeit.
Was treibt das C++
so die ganze Zeit? Das C++ Gremium.
Außer sich noch
ekligere Syntax ausdenken.
By the way, wo wir bei ekligen Syntax sind.
Pass mal auf.
Ach gut, das ist jetzt unfair
Okay, gucken wir uns das Heise an, weil
Weil die versuchen es wenigstens noch schön zu machen, ne
Aber es ist halt nicht schön
Guckt euch das schon mal an
Wenn ich das hier sehe
Doppelpunkt Hütchen-Char-Doppelpunkt
What the fuck, Alter
Standard-Same-Deckel-Type-X
Okay, das gibt's schon länger
Das ist aber halt, Alter, diese Sprache ist so unglaublich hässlich
Und so unglaublich wir
Ich weiß nicht, was die da treiben
Guckt euch das mal an
WTF, was ist das für eine abartige Kack-Syntax
What the fuck
Guckt euch das hier mal an
WTF
Da fällt mir gar nichts mehr zu ein, ey
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Und was ist das?
Das ist irgendeine Lambda, oder?
Vermutlich
Alter, ich denke
Mir fehlen die Worte
Okay, und wir dürfen nicht vergessen
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, das ist ein Heise-Artikel
Also das, was wir hier sehen
Hat jemand wirklich handcrafted
Okay, vielleicht auch AI-crafted
Ähm
Und das ist ein gutes Beispiel, ist so lesbar
Guckt euch diesen Scheiß mal an
Klammer auf
Also es geht, okay
Konstexprimier
Standard String
Okay, okay, okay
Was soll hier?
Enum to String
Ah, geht das jetzt offiziell?
Kann man jetzt offiziell einen Enum zu einem String dingsen?
Dazu hat man sonst immer extra Libraries gebraucht
Warum auch immer das bisher nicht ging
Und vor allem, warum braucht man da so was hässliches zu?
gibt es wirklich jemand der diesen ganzen scheiß noch versteht in einem
zustand also dass das ist wahrscheinlich eine funktion eine kompakt funktion die
so angelegt wird oder sowas rate ich jetzt mal ja so dann wird geguckt
in default value oder sowas und dann wird gesagt eckige klammer auf doppel
Punkt Expand Standard
Meta Elumerators of
Hütchen
E
Und dann
Zwei Pfeile
Was?
Zwei Pfeile und dann kommt so eine Art Lambda oder sowas?
Oder keine Ahnung
Was es ist, Alter
If Value gleich
Doppelpunkt
Ehh
Gibt es wirklich jemand
Der das gebaut hat
Und sich danach gesagt hat
Jawoll Leute
Das ist es
Das sollten wir so machen
Das muss so in den Standard rein
Das ist es, genau so muss es sein
Diese Sprache Alter
Das ist wirklich
Ich sag es immer wieder
C++ ist die beschissenste Sprache
die versucht nicht beschissen zu sein ja es gibt so sachen wie brainfuck oder
white space oder sowas die versuchen ja beschissen zu sein
aber c++ versucht nicht beschissen zu sein das ist die beschissenste sprache
die nicht versucht beschissen zu sein
kein wunder dass es da so viel undefined behavior gibt und irgendwelche compiler
Implementationsdinger, die nicht passen
und uns ewig brauchen, bis was implementiert ist.
Bei der Komplexität und bei dem
Durcheinander musst du dich da echt nicht wundern.
Ja, Potato Bob,
du kannst ja wirklich froh sein.
Das ist wirklich als D++, wie gesagt,
die beschissenste Sprache,
die eigentlich nicht beschissen sein will.
Aber halt trotzdem
massive beschissen ist.
Wenn ich mir das hier alles angucke...
Oh, ich dachte, es gibt Kommentare.
So nach dem Motto, boah, ist das hässlich.
Vielleicht nützlich, okay.
Aber lesbar, ja.
Okay, der erklärt jetzt natürlich schon mal,
warum es nicht schlimm ist,
warum es hässlich sein darf.
Wir können es einfach auch nicht hässlich machen.
Das wäre doch auch mal was.
Oh, wisst ihr? Chat, Chat,
Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat. Wir gucken jetzt
mal. Wir gucken jetzt mal.
Das interessiert uns doch alle.
Was sagt das
Microcontroller-Forum
zu C++
Reflection?
Hahaha.
Mal gucken.
Was? VB.net Reflection?
Nein, nein, nein.
C++, Alter.
C++ Reflection.
Und kann man das Ganze vielleicht
sortieren irgendwie?
Nach Datum
oder so?
Nur Forumsbeiträge?
Gibt nicht.
Äh.
Die benutzen Google,
um das forum zu durchsuchen und das forum hat keine eigene suche
was das
aber so den postfach
Die haben dazu noch nichts geschrieben.
Das wundert mich jetzt aber.
Ich dachte, ich will jetzt da eigentlich mal wieder ein bisschen
Gestreiter sehen.
Ha.
Also wer das Mikrocontroller-Forum
nicht kennt, Leute, das ist
das mit Abstand schlimmste
Forum, was ich kenne.
Das ist so unglaublich dumm.
Und wie da geschrieben wird, Alter.
Also wenn man
graue Haare wachsen lassen will,
liest man ein paar
Beiträge aus dem Mikrocontroller vor.
Aber das wollen wir jetzt nicht machen.
Da trinke ich mich noch mehr auf.
Nachdem ich schon getriggert wurde durch C++ Reflections und Tags.
Ja.
Das wäre tatsächlich ein ganz guter
Trigger-Troll-Post dafür.
Dann erzählen die dir, dass man ihre Mikrocontroller nur in gutem C89 programmieren kann, weil es das einzig wahre ist oder sowas.
Ja, jetzt wurde ich etwas sidetracked.
Lasst uns mal der Gelegenheit doch gerade mal gucken.
Was trendet denn auf GitHub so?
Clear Language.
Lasst mich raten, Leute, bevor ich gucke.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Trendet.
Erstmal eine Runde nochmal zur Beruhigung.
Oh, der Hai frisst Fische.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so beruhigend ist.
Ist gerade der Wal vorbeigeschoben.
Ich habe nicht geguckt.
Weißt du mal, Askequarium hat die Zukunft
Predicted
Ab und zu kommt da mal ein Wal vorbeigeschwommen
Ja
Gucken, wie lang es dauert
Bis der Wal vorbeigeschwommen kommt
Wobei Timmy würde ja nicht mal schwimmen
Da ist er
Ascii Timmy.
Okay, jetzt können wir uns den GitHub Trends widmen.
Also.
Cloak Browser.
Stealth Chromium.
That passes every bot detection test.
Oh, das ist cool.
Das ist tatsächlich nice.
Wenn man irgendwas scrapen will.
Ich hatte schon manchmal den Anwendungsfall, dass ich was automatisieren will auf Webseiten,
die nicht so scharf darauf waren, automatisiert zu werden.
Zum Beispiel, kann ich ja mal erzählen,
Ich habe ein paar Domains bei Porkbun.
Warum ich die bei denen habe, ist, weil die damals die mit Abstand günstigsten Domain-Registrare waren.
Da habe ich ein paar Domains.
Und es gab mal Zeiten, da hatten die noch keine DNS-API für Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate und sowas.
und da habe ich mit
Puppeteer, das ist ja, das ist quasi so was
wie Playwright, also quasi so eine
Browser-Automatisierung, da kann man Chrome
fernsteuern, habe ich mit
einem Headless-Chrome
quasi mein eigenes
DNS-API gebastelt, also
indem der einfach auf der Webseite
klickt, legt DNS-Einträge
an, fügt einen TXT-Rekord
hinzu und sowas, also ich habe quasi
das automatisiert, dass ich dort
Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate ausstellen kann
mit einer Browser-Automatisierung.
Also quasi, man hat ein
Third-Bot genommen, hat gesagt, Custom Hook,
hat das Skript übergeben.
Und die waren da nicht so scharf drauf,
dass man ihre Seite crawlt.
Und eines Tages
haben die mich sogar
ausgesperrt und haben
gesagt, ey, wir mögen das
nicht, dass man unsere Webseite
crawlt. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay,
okay, schaltet mich mal bitte
wieder frei, weil die haben mich direkt
IP geblockt. Ich war ja auch
Blöd, ich habe das von meinem Rechner daheim und der IP daheim gemacht.
Aber gut, ich meine, da will ich es ja letztendlich auch ausführen.
Und da haben die mich IP-Blocked, da habe ich denen an Support geschrieben und gesagt,
ja, okay, okay, ich mache nichts mehr, könnt ihr mich bitte wieder freischalten.
Und dann haben die mich wieder freigeschaltet.
Und jetzt war ich richtig dumm.
Ich habe dann dieses Skript aufgemacht und habe das Skript noch ein bisschen editiert.
Und aus Versehen habe ich das Skript ausgeführt, wo noch denen ihre URL drin stand.
und das Skript hat sich dann wieder zehnmal versucht einzulocken
und es hat mich wieder gesperrt.
Und dann musste ich da nochmal hinschreiben
und sagen, ja Leute, ich bin's nochmal.
Ich hab mich aus Versehen wieder ausgesperrt.
Ich hab nur aus Versehen dieses Skript ausgeführt.
Ich wollte euch gar nicht mehr crawlen.
Bitte schaltet mich nochmal frei.
Und die haben mich tatsächlich auch nochmal freigeschaltet.
Und seitdem habe ich Abstand davon genommen,
denen ihre Webseite zu crawlen.
Weil ich mich nicht nochmal aussperren wollte
Und vor allem, ich denen es nicht nochmal glaubhaft ein drittes Mal erzählen kann
Dass ich wieder aus Versehen das gleiche Skript ausgeführt habe
Nun ja, für sowas wäre das natürlich nice
Ja, wenn man nicht bemerkt werden möchte
Mit irgendwelchen Detection-Dingern
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, dagegen hätte der Cloud-Browser auch nicht geholfen
Weil die haben einfach nur erkannt
So und so viele Login-Versuche
In so und so vielen Minuten von der gleichen IP
wir sperren mal da hätte es ja auch nichts gebracht aber gucken wir mal was das hier ist
chromium job in playboy repleist source level finger printing patches aha das ist in der tat
sehr nice es ist wirklich cool weil ich hab ich hab bei mir auf der alten arbeit da hatten wir
ein Spam-Filteranbieter, wie nennt man sowas?
So ein Spam-Detection, E-Mail-Spam-Detection-Dienstleister,
der quasi unsere Mails gescannt hat, ob das Spam ist
und dann in Quarantäne geschoben hat.
Und die hatten, was halt echt absolut lächerlich ist,
die hatten keine API, um Spam-E-Mails irgendwie aus Quarantäne freizugeben und sowas,
was halt echt richtig, richtig dämlich ist.
und wir haben es denen auch ein paar mal gesagt.
Die haben übrigens die beste Antwort geliefert,
als Ausrede, die habe ich mir gemerkt.
Und zwar, wir haben den Anbieter, keine Ahnung,
drei, vier Mal gefragt, so nach dem Motto,
Leute, wie wäre es denn, wenn ihr meine API anbietet
und sei es nur um zu sagen,
ey, alle E-Mails an diesen Empfänger bitte aus Quarantäne freigeben.
Ja, irgendwas, irgendeinen Endpunkt, den man callen kann.
Und da haben die gesagt,
oh ja, das ist eine super Idee.
und das wollen noch mehr Kunden haben,
deswegen haben wir intern einen Feature-Request dazu offen.
Und das haben die jedes Mal gesagt.
Die haben jedes Mal gesagt, oh ja, das ist eine tolle Idee,
wir haben dazu auch schon einen Feature-Request offen.
Das heißt, wenn euch mal irgendjemand mit irgendwas auf den Sack geht,
dann macht einfach intern einen Feature-Request dazu auf
und immer wenn euch dann wieder oder der gleiche auf den Sack geht,
könnt ihr sagen, oh ja, das ist ja eine geile Idee,
dazu haben wir schon einen Feature-Request offen.
Das hört sich dann nämlich so an, als passiert da gleich was.
Aber die haben, boah, fünf Jahre oder so wie das lief, haben die das nicht gemacht.
Einfach sagen, oh, das ist ganz toll.
Dann freuen die Leute sich ja auch noch so nach dem Motto, oh ja, ich bin nicht der Einzige, bald gibt's das.
Aber vorwegen, das gibt's bald.
Ja, Feature Request auf.
Und das war ein Anbieter.
Da musste ich dann, also habe ich auch Padless Chrome, was geskriptet.
Was alle E-Mails freigibt, an eine spezielle oder von einer speziellen Adresse, ich weiß es, ich glaube an eine spezielle Adresse, sollte das freigegeben werden.
Und das lief dann ein paar Mal am Tag und hat das freigegeben, aber manchmal, manchmal ist es gefailt und gecrashed und dann erst beim nächsten Lauf wieder durchgelaufen.
Und ich vermute, dass das auf denen ihrer Seite irgendeine Bot-Detection war.
Was sie auch richtig detektet haben.
Aber es lief oft genug durch.
Ja, und da wäre sowas hier natürlich echt praktisch gewesen.
Cloak Browser.
A real Chromium Binary with Fingerprints modified.
Das ist richtig nice.
Anti-Bot-Systems score it as normal browser,
because it is a normal browser.
Ach, damit kommt man an diesen
Captures vorbei.
Sehr nice.
Die Frage ist nur,
das ist jetzt ja wieder so ein Wettrennen,
die Frage ist nur, wie lange.
Ob man nicht doch irgendwie erkennen
kann, ob es der Cloak-Browser ist.
Aber wenn die das richtig machen, eigentlich nicht, oder?
Replacing for Python and JavaScript.
Ja gut.
Ich hätte es gerne noch für .NET gehabt, aber JavaScript ist auch okay.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass du jetzt ein Handy brauchst, um ein Captcha zu lösen mit Google Play oder Apple?
Ne, hab ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Das ist aber ein wirklich nices Projekt, das werde ich mir mal bookmarken.
Das finde ich nice.
das kann man mal sicherlich
gut gebrauchen.
Wenn man dann mal was hat,
wofür man es eben gebrauchen kann.
Das finde ich gut. Leute, das ist ja
wirklich Premiere. Wir haben seit
Monaten mal wieder ein Projekt
gefunden in den GitHub Trends, was nicht AI
ist und wo ich sage, ey,
das ist ja mal wirklich was Sinnvolles,
Praktisches. Das will ich
mir mal bookmarken,
um es zu verwenden.
Oder es gut gebookmarkt zu haben.
ok geht weiter was google recaptcha play service requirement
Wallet ist schon ein bisschen abfuck, ne?
Do not, wir consenten nicht.
Habe ich hier...
Was ist denn das hier überhaupt für ein Browser?
Ist doch Chrome, oder?
Warum habe ich hier keinen...
ähm...
U-Block installiert?
Warum habe ich hier keinen U-Block installiert?
Mal gucken, ob er auch der richtige ist.
Ok, U-Block am Start
Google's next gen recapture system
could spell trouble for
the Google phones
Ja, das ist Google der Enendorn im Auge
Was aber halt extrem
suckt
Wobei die meisten Leute
installieren doch auch auf alternativen Firmwares
Zumindest so die minimal
Google Play APIs, oder?
weiß ich, ob das wirklich so ein großes Problem ist.
Aber es sagt halt,
dass immer wieder an allen
Ecken versucht wird, es einzuschränken,
wie man sein Gerät
benutzen kann. Ach, das geht auch nicht.
Ah, toll.
Agent Memory,
AI.
Moment, Entropic hat Financial Services?
Was?
Cloud for Financial Services.
Okay.
Hebel mit KI, oder was?
AI.
Bann.
Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum...
Okay, Bann hätte wahrscheinlich sonst auch viele Sterne bekommen.
Ich habe mich dazu schon ausgelassen, ganz ehrlich.
Es gibt auch schon ganz viele Issues zu dem Rust Rewrite,
dass es nicht safe Rust ist und bla bla bla.
Aber ich glaube, dass der Rewrite, beziehungsweise kann man das Rewrite nennen, der Vibe-Coded Rewrite von Sig zu Rust,
dass das einfach nur wieder irgendein Marketing-Stunt von Anthropic ist, um zu zeigen, guck mal hier,
wir haben eine JavaScript-Runtime per KI geportet oder irgendwie sowas.
Keine Ahnung.
Refactor unsaved for static strings.
Hui.
Kann mir jemand erklären, warum das SIG-Port heißt?
Müsste es nicht Rust-Port heißen?
Weil SIG ist der Originale.
Ist das Original.
Das liest sich jetzt ja so, als wäre Rust das Original und sie porten es zu SIG.
Nee, nee, es war SICK und sie porten das zu Rust.
Warum heißt das SICK-Port?
Man weiß es nicht.
Das ist doch garantiert auch per KI geschrieben, ne?
656 Files changed.
Also wenn das nicht irgendein
Vibe-Coded-Comet ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Haben die bestimmt
Vibe-Coded?
Oder gut, sowas kannst du auch searchen und replacen.
AI.
Das haben wir schon mal gesehen.
Das finde ich ein interessantes Projekt.
So Presence Detection mit WiFi-Signalen.
Kann man auch mit dem ESP32 machen, ganz merkwürdig.
Lightning Fast Censorship Resistant Proxy.
Für die China-Chinesen.
Wer weiß, vielleicht.
Vielleicht brauchen wir sowas auch bald.
Ich meine, die Zeichen sind ja da mit Altersverifikation und vielleicht VPN verbieten und solchen Geschichten.
Die Zeichen sind ja da, also vielleicht brauchen wir sowas auch bald.
Wir machen es ja immer lustig über die China-Chinesen oder was da in anderen Ländern so abgeht.
Aber bei uns ist das alles kein Problem.
Wir sind da auch auf dem besten Weg hin.
The React Doctor.
Your agent writes bad react.
Ah, okay, KI.
Ein was?
Ein Gaussian
Splat Editor.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Super Splat Editor.
Äh.
What the fuck?
Alter.
Was bin...
Boah, krass, dass sowas im Browser läuft, oder?
Okay, okay.
Alter.
Es ist ein wenig
Ein wenig laggy
Bei mir im Browser
Kann das sein, dass das nicht
GPU beschleunigt unter Linux im Firefox
Hier läuft gerade
Ist das vielleicht nicht
GPU accelerated
Wollen wir da mal kurz gucken, ist das GPU accelerated
Ich glaube schon, oder
Ne, das ist nicht GPU accelerated
Ist das? Okay, dann gucken wir mal was anderes
Wir gucken mal was anderes
Ist das? Wir machen es gerade mal wieder zu
Vielleicht liegt das auch an meinem RAM
Da ich zu wenig RAM habe
Wir machen mal Chrome auf
Okay, Chromium vielleicht
Vielleicht ist es ein Chromium Accelerated
Alter, wie dieses Kack
Wie mir dieser Kack-Key-Dings da auf den Sack geht
Okay, ein Chrome
ruckelt es auch
Ja, keine Ahnung
Das könnte wieder Linux und
GPU im Browser sein
Aber das probieren wir mal unter Windows aus
Super Splat
Super
Punkt
Ne, Super Splat
Punkt Ad
Unter Windows müsste das flüssig laufen, oder?
Ey, super, super flüssig
Perfekt
Aber es ist schon krass, was man
mittlerweile im Browser machen kann, oder?
Das ist doch brutal
Er stellt es hier im Browser
Ist das, ist das
Wie funktioniert denn das?
Sind das
3D-Scans oder was ist das?
Irgendwelche Scans,
die man dann
dann irgendwie
zu 3D-Objekten umwandelt oder so?
Oder was ist das überhaupt?
Was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend?
Ich meine, das sieht schon fotorealistisch aus.
Und ich würde sagen, weil es halt eben auch Bilder sind.
Weil die ruckelt es nicht unter Linux.
Vielleicht ist meine Grafikkarte auch einfach zu schlecht.
In dem Mini-PC.
Okay, hier kann man nicht weiterlaufen, oder?
Oder?
Doch, kann man.
Da läuft jemand mit einer 3D-Kamera durch.
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, das heißt aber auch, man kann damit jetzt nicht was modellieren, was es noch nicht gibt in dem Sinn.
Schon nice.
Aber Animationen gehen natürlich nicht
Das ist ja logisch
Wenn es Bilder sind, Animationen gehen nicht
Was zum
Ich hab gedacht, jetzt kommen gleich irgendwelche
Anime Girls wieder, was
Weil das wäre ja schon echt verwunderlich
Wenn nicht
Okay
Es geht schon los
Leute, ich scrolle nicht weiter, was es hier noch alles gibt
Okay, komm, wir trauen uns mal
Für die Weeps unter uns
Okay, doch nichts
Doch nichts so schlimm
Hier, so, Weep
Nee, gibt nichts, okay
Ey, keine Ahnung
Aber das sieht nach einer coolen Sache aus.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, wofür ich das verwenden würde.
Ah.
Das muss ich mir nachher mal angucken.
Eine coole Sache.
Ja, ich habe den Eindruck, dass das bei mir unter Linux
irgendwie die Grafikkarte nicht benutzt.
Chat, wir hatten doch mal letztens
Wir hatten doch letztens mal irgendwas, wie man unter Linux testen kann, ob die Grafikkarte auch ordentlich benutzt wird
Hab schon wieder vergessen
Wir hatten doch irgend so ein
Ach ne, das war der, das war der Ulama Benchmark
Das war der Ulama Benchmark
Moment, wir schauen mal, wir schauen mal kurz, ob
Ja
Schauen wir mal kurz
Splat
Schauen wir mal, ob der
Ob die Grafikkarte irgendwie benutzt wird
Ja, ja, oh, oh, oh
Die wird benutzt, Leute
Meine Grafikkarte ist einfach zu schlecht
Guck mal hier, die wird bis zum Anschlag benutzt
Seht ihr das?
Meine Grafikkarte ist einfach zu schlecht
Ja, das ist eine Onboard-Grafikkarte
Die wird benutzt bis
Bis zum Anschlag, die Grafikkarte
Ich meine, das ist auch, guck mal
Das ist eine Radeon 780M
Das ist schon nicht die geilste Karte
Also das scheint doch ein bisschen Leistung zu brauchen
Okay
Dann schauen wir mal weiter
Was trendet denn bei Kobol?
Wieder das gleiche wie das letzte Mal wahrscheinlich
Jawohl
Ähm, okay
Was trendet bei... Oh, Blazingly Fast.
Was trendet bei Rust?
GPU-Stresstest.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Was da, ne?
Aber da müssen wir mal kurz
noch ein Terminal aufmachen.
Und NVTop starten.
Äh, nicht NVTop.
NVTop.
Start testing.
3D Rendering Test.
Start Test.
Okay, und jetzt?
Exzellente Performance.
Ja, Moment mal.
Extreme Effects.
Ultra Detailed.
Und wie viel FPS?
120 FPS.
Das geht doch.
Okay.
Scene Complexity.
Bam. Start Test.
Oh.
Okay.
Ja gut.
irgendwann kommt halt auch mal so eine Onboard
ne
also relativ schnell kommt halt so eine Onboard
Grafikkarte
auch mal an ihre Grenzen
was gibt es da sonst noch für Tests
Artikel System Test
Shader Performance Test.
Es laggt.
Okay, machen wir mal Basic.
Okay.
240 FPS.
Mit...
Gemandelbrotet.
Ich dachte, das zoomt da jetzt rein oder so.
Aber das macht es auch mit 42 FPS.
Naja.
Gut. Whatever.
Also, was trendet denn bei Rust so?
Gut, das Band trendet, wundert mich nicht.
Apropos Kobol.
Hat jemand auch das Bruder-Scout immer Referenz zu Goblins?
Moment, Moment.
Du willst Kobol-Vibe-Coden mit Cloud, sehe ich das richtig?
Gut, warum nicht?
Besser als Kobol von Hand schreiben.
Auf jeden Fall.
Eine 3D Kamera kostet zwischen 30 und 40k.
Schnapper.
Richtiger Schnapper.
Okay, also, was trendet denn sonst hier bei Rust?
Bann, klar.
AI.
Nochmal das da.
Pyrefly.
Was?
A fast type check and language server for Python.
Moment.
In Rust.
Okay, warum nicht?
Ob das Vibe-coded ist?
Lass uns mal checken, ob das
vibe-coded ist
Ähm, Source?
Wo ist das Source-Verzeichnis?
Chat, bin ich blind? Wo ist das Source-Verzeichnis?
Source?
Gibt's nicht Crates? Gibt's
Pyref
Python
Source
Äh, keine Ahnung
Dunder
er ist
das stellt sich so wirklich viel text drin oder lippe es also es hat ein
bisschen vibe coding leer
Weißt du, gerade solche Dinger hier, das wirkt immer ein bisschen nach, nach gevibecoded.
Weil keiner, also normalerweise
kein halbwegs
fähiger Programmierer
würde über einen
Funktionsaufruf
add comment section range
einen Kommentar schreiben
so
make no mistake, think extra hard
genau
Also das ist bestimmt teilweise
Vibe-Coded, das Ding.
Aber ist ja auch nicht schlimm.
Solange die Leute wissen, was sie machen
und das auch durchsteigen,
habe ich ja nichts dagegen.
Na gut.
3D Reconstruction
for All.
Was soll denn das sein?
3D Reconstruction for All.
Brusch.
Was?
Moment, das Ding erstellt aus Bildern 3D Objekte oder was?
Oh, das ist ja cool.
Das ist ja cool.
Also man muss wirklich sagen, es sind heute...
Okay, das ist natürlich mit AI, Maschine, aber es sind heute teilweise schon Sachen möglich, wo man früher gedacht hätte, das geht nicht.
Und jetzt wird die 3D... Achso, ich hab gehört, die Katze wird jetzt 3D-t.
trotzdem ganz coole sache nicht dass ich jemals brauchen würde
super intelligence an die hauptlos auf
ich glaube auch er
rast übung helix die auch für ki zeug mit
Tilly.
AI Meeting Assistant.
Alles klar.
Litter.
Hat das was mit Katzen zu tun?
No Description.
Native iOS
Enter Client for Codex. Aha.
Codex. Turbo Repo.
AI.
Static Analysis
for GitHub. Okay.
Quick Transport.
Weg ist doch dieses Google-HTTP, oder?
Okay, oh ja, waren ein paar ganz interessante Sachen.
Guck mal, was bei Go trendet.
Was trendet in Go?
Okay, das hatten wir heute schon.
Hatten wir heute auch schon.
Master DNS VPN.
Advanced DNS Tunneling VPN for Censorship.
brav vielleicht auch bald telegraf das das material nicht gedacht das ist auch schon uralt
das ist das ist irgendwas für observable t stellst du mir sagt der name was ich habe es
noch nie benutzt kann die trend habe ich mal lange zeit gerne benutzt für einfache web server
die letzten kubzertifikate brauchen weil kari ist quasi eine zeile und du hast also wenn du wenn du
einen server mit einer china ist ja also wenn du irgendwelche statischen content surfen willst und
ein gültiges letzten kubzertifikat haben willst ist es halt eine zeile mit kari dafür ist schon
sehr leise leider ist die config mittlerweile ziemlich eklig geworden nicht so eklig wie die
traffic konflikt ganz ehrlich traffic hat so ziemlich die hässlichste konflikt
die ich mir vorstellen kann für von vater tps aber da ist mir okay apache
ist mir nicht wirklich lieber aber da ist mir nix um vielfaches lieber
zielkürzigen geht okay das hat verkehrt depper das habe ich jetzt durcheinander
gebracht es gibt doch auch für dort netz in irgendeine datenbank geschichte die
Depper heißt.
Stackcharm.
Schauen wir mal, was sie für ein Logo haben.
Achso.
Ich hab gedacht,
jetzt kommt irgendein Weep-Logo.
Eats Book.
china chinesen kram china chinesen kram okay und als letztes was trennt denn in
dem wir gucken jetzt mal der chat was was trennt moment shell muss man dann
wahrscheinlich suchen oder shell was trennt er den patch das habe ich glaube
ich noch nie geguckt trennt aber ob irgendwas skills ok super powers agentic
skill framework na gut omachi natürlich was sonst der hype ist
auch schon wieder komplett vorbei, oder?
Komplett durch.
Das war mal zwei Wochen
voll gehypt und jetzt
ist das
ja, wieder
in der Bedeutungslosigkeit irgendwie verschwunden.
Sniper.
One on one
on Rust, würde ich sagen.
Designer Skills, AI.
Docker Steam Headless.
Aha.
Für Nvidia-Stells.
Heidel.
Was?
Your Development Envoy.
Das kenne ich nicht. Was soll das sein?
Okay, als letztes gucken wir, was in .NET
so trennt. Nicht ASP.NET, Alter.
Dort.
Muss man das so schreiben?
.NET, oder?
C-Sharp. Muss ich suchen.
So.
Was ist das denn?
Your Development Environment.
Hä?
Ist das ein Hyperland-Setup oder was?
Oder was bin ich hier sehend?
Okay, das ist
irgendeine Hyperland-Config.
Ja, gut.
Benutze ich eh nicht.
Was ist das?
Where the goblins came from?
Was?
Alter, ich raste aus
Dieses Kack-Wallet, ey
Kann sich das mal verpissen?
Woher die goblins kamen?
Ist es schlecht escaped oder soll das wirklich so aussehen?
Können wir das vielleicht auch in Englisch lesen?
Anscheinend gibt es da keinen Schalter.
Können wir hier
EN
US machen?
Ah, yes.
Okay, mit GPT 5.1
angefangen, haben die
eine komische Gewohnheit gezeigt,
die Models, und zwar
increasingly mentioned
Goblins, Cremlins and other
Creatures.
Warum?
Die Goplins
multiplieren.
Boah, das ist ja ein ewig langer Artikel.
Das kann ich mir nicht alles durchlesen, aber...
Gibt es da TLDR?
Okay, der Nerd-Modus
hat die anderen beeinflusst. Okay.
Das ist ja lustig.
Ja, so kann es gehen, ne?
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch?
Office CLI.
Office CLI ist der erste und beste
Office Suite Purpose-Built
AI Agents.
Was sonst?
Screenbox
VLC-based
Media Player
für UWP
jetzt mal eine doofe Frage
also es ist
bestimmt, wenn man Windows Desktop
Entwicklung lernen will, auch wenn UWP
abfuck hoch 10, aber okay
ist ja schön und gut
das geht ja nur mit Code Signing und Gedöns
aber
warum
außer dass es halt
Windows KQI hoch 10 aussieht
da kann jetzt der Entwickler nichts für
das ist halt dieses Windows Design Ding
das ist halt, naja, kann man nicht drüber streiten
ähm, warum
ein LibVLC-based Player,
wenn man auch einfach direkt VLC verwenden kann.
Kann mir das irgendjemand sinnvoll erklären?
Also warum?
Ist WinUI 3 wirklich ein Nachfolger von UWP?
Ich dachte, WinUI 3 ist quasi das UI-Framework von UWP.
Das neue UI-Framework von UWP.
Aber kann auch andere Sachen targeten.
Aber keine Ahnung, bei Microsoft blicke ich da nicht durch.
Okay, wir gucken mal kurz.
Wo ist denn der Source-Code hier drin?
Hier.
Screenbox Core.
Factories, Messages, Playback.
iMedia Player CS.
Okay, das ist einfach nur Interfaces, hätte man sich denken können.
Playback Audio Track CS.
Object Oriented.
C Sharp.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht Vibe Coded.
Das erkennt man gleich.
Videotrack CS.
Gut, brauche ich nicht.
Wundert mich nur, weil man könnte einfach direkt VLC nehmen.
Deswegen, okay, okay, verstehe.
Pile, Modern Pile Manager kennen wir auch schon.
Also haben wir auch schon mal ein paar Mal oft gelesen.
Deftoils haben wir auch schon gelesen.
Avalonia. Avalonia hat's verdient.
Leider bin ich überhaupt kein Fan von XAML.
Wobei man Avalonia mittlerweile ja wohl auch ohne XAML programmieren kann,
sondern direkt mit Code.
Ich mein, das ging in WPF auch, aber abfuck.
Ich glaub, in Avalonia geht das besser.
Ich hab da letztens mal irgendwo ein Beispiel zugesehen.
V-Pad.
Was auch immer. V-Pad.
Moment.
Chat was was ist hier los
Warum habe ich jetzt hier so ein doppelten mauszeiger weiß man nicht was was bin ich hier sehend
Auf Steam gratis.
Oder installiere es in deine WPF-Applikation.
Alles klar.
Moment, habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen?
Dass der in Puppes da rausguckt?
Na klar, na klar, na klar.
Na klar.
Die Contributor, guck mal Leute.
Die Leute, die hier Contributed haben.
Da siehst du auch sofort, was Sache ist.
weeps unite naja gut warum nicht
auf am rhein positiv
nach pull request
Eigentlich ist die Idee ganz witzig.
Moment da gibt es auch mods dafür.
Ja, Katze als Skin wäre mir auch lieber.
Gibt es bestimmt, oder?
YouTube Downloader, warum brauche ich das in .NET nochmal?
Warum kann ich nicht einfach YouTube-DLP benutzen?
Ja.
Max, wie stehst du zu Catgirls?
Habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken zu gemacht, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber ich glaube, mir sind echte Cats lieber als Catgirls.
Also, als Haustiere.
Aha, zum Linux-Distribution runterladen.
Bestimmt KI.
Muss das gar nicht lesen.
Wenn es von Microsoft ist, ist es eh wipecoded.
Ich finde das andere.
RF-Programmer, wie stehst du denn zu Catgirls?
So, haben wir alle Trends durch? Es waren ja heute in der Tat mal einige interessante Projekte dabei und nicht nur KI, KI, KI, AI, AI.
So, mal schauen, ob es neue Updates gibt. Ich meine, wir haben immerhin schon seit knapp einer Stunde nicht mehr aktualisiert. Das geht ja nicht.
Was? Keine neuen Updates?
Da komme ich aber schon ganz schön outdated mit meiner Distribution vor.
Das ist bestimmt schon die nächste Privilege Escalation raus und die ist noch nicht gepatcht.
Wer weiß, RF-Programmer, wer weiß.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das in nächster Zeit erleben werden, JustPlayer.de.
Er schreibt, er freut sich, wenn der Moment weg ist, wenn der AI-Hype weg ist und wieder ordentlich arbeiten kann.
Das wird in nächster Zeit nicht passieren.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass es komplett wieder verschwinden wird.
Weil an sich ist das ja schon was Nices.
Wenn man das halt als Unterstützung verwendet und nicht unbedingt jetzt als, ich habe keine Ahnung von dem, was ich eigentlich mache und lasse mir von irgendeinem Model irgendwas auskacken und poste es dann auf Reddit als mein neues Projekt oder sowas.
Das gibt es so oft mittlerweile auf Reddit-Posts, so nach dem Motto, hier, ich habe ein neues Tool, ein neues was auch immer programmiert, show Reddit.
Und dann stellst du fest, okay, irgendwas in einem halben Tag mit Cloud-Code zusammengeschustertes, Vibe-Codedes.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es in nächster Zeit tatsächlich mehr Positionen geben wird,
die sich explizit um AI-generierten Code kümmern müssen oder um AI-generierte Sachen.
Von Probe gucken bis Mist fixen bis wirklich gute Prompts basteln.
vor allem auch ein bisschen aufräumen was die kaiso produziert ob das dann
spaß macht es wieder was anderes
ja gut dass das den eindruck habe ich auch und ich glaube das liegt ein
bisschen daran weil die sich halt untereinander alle brüsten wollen mit
Wir sind jetzt, keine Ahnung, AI first und wir sind jetzt hier bei 80% vom Code wird nur noch per AI.
Weißt du, weil die beim Golf spielen oder sowas sich dann gegenseitig auf dicke Hose machen wollen, wie krass KI-mäßig sie schon unterwegs sind.
Habe ich so den Eindruck, dass das mit daher kommt, ja.
Ich bin der Meinung, bei mir auf der Arbeit, wir machen das eigentlich ganz sinnvoll.
Wir haben einen eigenen Fork von ChatGPT.
Also das ist kein eigener Fork, das habe ich jetzt falsch ausgedrückt.
Man kann ChatGPT quasi für sich zugeschnitten bei Microsoft kaufen.
Das geht.
Das läuft dann irgendwo bei Azure oder so.
Und die garantieren einem halt, ey, inwieweit das stimmt, keine Ahnung, ja.
Aber die garantieren einem dann halt auch, dass die Daten nicht abfließen und in Europa bleiben und bla bla blub.
Ob das wirklich stimmt, kann ja letztendlich eh keiner überprüfen.
Ja und da haben wir so einen internen Chat-GPT-Fork, den wir verwenden können.
Das ist eigentlich ganz sinnvoll.
Dann haben wir noch als Visual Studio Code Plugins können wir Gemini verwenden.
Ist auch ganz nice.
Das wird dann auf das jeweilige Google Projekt gebucht, was man einträgt.
Also da kann man auch schon sehen, was man verbrät.
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut gemacht.
Jetzt bin ich hier sehend.
One layer for collecting your
to training stream data
Das klicke ich jetzt nicht an
So, dann haben wir uns die Trends ja
zu Gemüte geführt
Oder hatte ich das schon durchgescrollt?
Ja, hatte ich schon, ja, alles schon durch
Top
Hab ich überhaupt, Moment
Hatte ich das vorher überhaupt auf this week stehen
oder hatte ich es auf
Jaja, ich hatte es auf This Week stehen.
Okay, gut.
Excellent.
Es soll ja Firmen geben, wo man mehr gelobt wird,
wenn man mehr talkt.
Da ist man halt mehr KI-Native oder so,
falls es dieses Wort gibt.
Kann schon sein.
Ich meine, es gibt, beziehungsweise gab ja auch Unternehmen,
die die Leute nach
Zeilencode, die sie
programmiert haben, irgendwie bewertet haben.
Was dann auch schon Schwachsinn war.
Ganz ehrlich,
wenn die mich irgendwie bewerten, beziehungsweise
bezahlen würden nach Tokens
verbraucht, dann würde ich den ganzen Tag
irgendwas da in der Schleife laufen
lassen, dass ich ganz viele Tokens
verbrauche und dann erzählen,
wie geil
fortschrittlich wir hier sind und wie viel
mir AI gebracht hat. Weil, nicht, dass
ich das dann wirklich denken würde, aber das ist das,
was die hören wollen. Und manchmal ist es
gar nicht so schlecht, man erzählt denen einfach, was sie hören
wollen, zum eigenen Vorteil.
Copilot is moving
to usage-based billing. Ach so,
gibt's keine Subscription mehr, wo du
so viel machen kannst, wie du willst.
Das ist natürlich, ja, es wird immer
teurer langsam, hä?
Wie war das?
Anthropic hat ihre Cloud-Code-Subscription
neuen Regeln
und so haben sie wieder umgestellt, nachdem
der Backlash zu groß war, ne?
Hat letztens im Chat einer geschrieben.
Ich hab das nicht weiter verfolgt dann.
Sowas bleibt aber halt im Kopf hängen.
Genauso wie im Kopf hängen bleibt,
dass Synology
nur noch quasi
offiziell zugelassene Festplatten akzeptiert.
Da haben sie ja, glaube ich, auch wieder einen Rückzieher gemacht.
Aber der Aufschrei ist im Kopf geblieben.
So, dann gucken wir doch mal, was es auf YouTube so gibt.
Ich wollte mir eigentlich ein Video zu angucken.
Das da.
MonkaS.
A hacker found a BitLocker backdoor.
Gucken, was da Sache ist.
Das habe ich heute Morgen schon irgendwo, ich glaube auf Reddit.
Auf Reddit habe ich das heute Morgen im Bett gelesen.
Dass BitLocker gepwned wurde.
Und mich würde jetzt mal interessieren, wie schlimm es ist.
Und was Microsoft wieder verkackt hat.
Beziehungsweise.
ob das der NSA-Backdoor ist,
den es seit Jahren schon gibt.
Und was mich viel eher interessieren würde,
ist, ob es denn wirklich gescheit implementiert ist.
Also sprich, ordentliche Verschlüsselung
muss eigentlich so funktionieren,
dass wenn der Schlüssel weg ist,
dass die Daten verloren sind.
Gut, es sei denn, man kann es Brut forcen.
Aber das muss so sein.
Es darf keine Recovery-Möglichkeit geben.
Schlüssel weg, Daten weg, fertig.
Ja, was vielleicht noch geht, ist, okay, einen zweiten Ersatzschlüssel oder einen zweiten Ersatz-Token oder irgendwas, ja.
Aber sagen wir so, wenn alle Passwörter weg sind oder wenn alle Secrets weg sind, müssen die Daten weg sein.
Weil ansonsten ist es nicht ordentlich verschlüsselt.
Ja, Veracrypt oder TrueCrypt früher auch, die machen das natürlich mit einem Zwischenschritt, ja.
Also, die Daten werden mit Keys verschlüsselt, mit fester Länge.
Das braucht man, damit IIS und sowas alles richtig performant ist.
Aber diese Keys sind dann mit eurem Passwort verschlüsselt.
Und manchmal auch sogar mit einer random Anzahl Iterations.
Wie oft das quasi applied wird.
So, und mit diesem Passwort entschlüsselst du deine Keys und mit den Keys entschlüsselst du dann deine Daten.
So, und wenn das, wenn sowohl die, entweder wenn die Keys weg sind, ist nicht so schlimm,
dann kannst du, falls du die Keys auf irgendeinem Recovery Medium hast, kannst du die wieder herstellen.
oder aber, was auch
einige Verschlüsselungstools machen ist,
die speichern die Keys einmal am Anfang
der Disk und einmal am Ende der Disk.
Und können die dann
zur Not wiederherstellen. Aber wenn die Keys
wiederhergestellt werden, bringen die dir auch nichts
ohne dein Passwort. Ja, das ist ja
der Knackpunkt an der Sache.
Also, Passwort weg, Daten
weg. So muss das sein.
Mal gucken, was BitLocker
verkackt hat. Oder besser
gesagt, was
die hier so verkackt haben.
Year of Our Lord, das ist
auch so ein typisches Kakao-Ding, oder?
Okay, jetzt muss ich mal aufpassen, dass ich da durchblicke.
Well, there was a recent incident where a security researcher stumbled upon a severe weakness in BitLocker,
perhaps even a backdoor maybe, that three-letter agencies have been using for years
to access people's data when they think it's protected.
Now in most cases, you would think that the Alphabet Boys would just get the BitLocker recovery key
from Microsoft directly in order to access encrypted...
Ja, das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum ich damals gesagt habe, ich werde BitLocker niemals verwenden.
Weil eines der ersten News, die ich über BitLocker gelesen habe, ist, dass Microsoft die Möglichkeit hat, quasi den Key zu recoveren. Also dass es einen Recover-Mechanismus gibt. Von irgendeiner anderen Stelle. Also irgendwo außer ihr habt eure Keys.
Und das ist halt was, wo ich mir denke, das widerspricht komplett dem Prinzip dahinter eigentlich.
Deswegen habe ich BitLocker direkt abgeschrieben oder abgehakt im Kopf, dass ich es nie verwenden werde.
Wie gesagt, die Keys alleine, wenn die das gescheit gemacht haben, die Keys alleine, ohne das Passwort für diese Keys, dürften dir nichts bringen.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß nur, wie VeraCrypt das macht.
Die generieren einen ganz langen Schlüssel, mit dem eure Daten verschlüsselt werden.
Aber dieser Schlüssel selbst ist mit eurem Passwort verschlüsselt. Das liegt daran, dass AES, also dieses Encryption-Verfahren, was die benutzen, damit das besonders effizient umgesetzt werden kann, programmiert technisch, müssen die Keys feste Längen, bestimmte Längen haben oder bestimmte Byte, wie nennt man das, Aligned sein.
Ja, also die müssen dann immer quasi zu irgendwelchen Byte-Grenzen, also es kann irgendwie 8, 16, 32 oder sowas.
Irgendwie sowas, das muss quasi immer, soll man sagen, eine feste Länge haben, dass das Performant funktioniert.
Und diese Keys selber sind dann mit eurem Passwort verschuldet, zumindest ist es bei Veracrypt so.
Ja.
Kann man nicht das Passwort hashen?
Dann bekommt man das Passwort in...
Frag mich nicht.
Security ist ein...
Gerade Verschlüsselung ist ein kompliziertes Thema.
Klingt erstmal so, als könnte man das machen.
Aber hat bestimmt andere Implikationen, warum es nicht...
keine gute Idee ist.
Ich kann es dir nicht erklären.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns das mal an.
So, if we look at this researcher's GitHub page,
they're hosting several repos that have Windows vulnerabilities.
These first two repos, called RedSun and BlueHammer,
are both privilege escalation tools that are designed to abuse Microsoft Defender...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, guckt mal, was ich hier sehe, Windows Defender.
...
es in Microsoft Defender einen JavaScript Interpreter gibt, der mit Rootrechten läuft.
Und der ließ sich damals austricksen mit manipulierten Dateien.
Muss ich jetzt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Ein JavaScript Interpreter mit Rootrechten im Windows Defender.
Habe ich dazu nicht gehört. Mal gucken, ob ich das noch finde.
Große Sicherheitslücke in Word und Windows Defender
Frau Lina war das
Ich erinnere mich noch, Dunkel
Guck mal, zu Zeiten
Zu Zeiten, wo ich noch regelmäßig Videos gemacht habe
Das Video hat keinen Bock
Das will nicht
... aus Russland und der Ecke.
Das ist jetzt ja erstmal nichts Besonderes, aber
ähm, dies...
... ja ja...
... ja, zumindest habe ich das da gezeigt.
Also das ist nicht das erste Mal,
dass es Probleme im Windows Defender gibt.
Wir können doch gerade nochmal angucken,
was das war.
Äh...
Warte mal, lass doch mal kurz gucken.
Chartcode.
2022.
Sogar nicht so lange her.
War das das überhaupt mit JavaScript?
Oder ist das noch länger her?
JavaScript spielte eine zentrale Rolle.
...
... in einen Privilege-Eskalation-Vektor.
Jetzt, bevor wir in die technischen Details kommen, wie all diese Exploiten funktionieren,
sprechen wir zuerst darüber, warum diese Exploiten, einige derjenigen, die nicht verpackt sind,
also es gibt immer noch Maschinen da draußen, die ihnen verletzt sind,
warum diese öffentlich auf der Internetseite für jede Skriptkette und ihre Mutter verwendet werden.
Also, im Hacking- und Penetrationstest-Welt...
nur weil ein ungepatchtes windows hat direkt angreifbar ist ich gehe mal ganz
stark davon aus dass es nicht reicht dass du auf irgendeine manipulierte html
seite oder so gehst oder http irgendwas abruf sondern du musst schon lokal
irgendwas ausführen können ja das kann durch eine browser
sicherheitslücke sein wurde dann aus der sandbox rauskommst dann etwas aber so
einfach mit irgendjemandem internet kann jetzt auf dem rechner von der oma das machen glaube ich nicht
Die Leute behalten die Details des Bug-Modells selbst, damit die Firma nicht von ihm aufhört und den Exploit-Müll verpackt.
Oder vielleicht, wenn sie diesen Meldewert zu jemandem geben, verkaufen sie diesen Code auf der Dark Web irgendwo,
aber sie pasten ihn nicht nur in eine öffentliche GitHub-Repo, um den ganzen Welt zu haben.
Der Grund, warum das passiert, ist, weil der Autor dieses Meldewerts ein Hacker ist, der fühlt sich, als hätte er Microsoft verfehlt.
bei Microsoft.
So, like I said, if you're one of the good guy hackers,
the usual course is that
you report the bug to the vendor
solange die noch eins haben,
weil sie nicht von AI-Slob erschlagen werden.
See a curl.
that are responsible for the product
and they give you some money.
Companies like Microsoft actually have a
dedicated arm of their company
for this called the Microsoft
Security Response Center.
And they pay you different
amounts, different bug bounties,
aufgrund der Produkte und Services, die Sie in ExploitN finden.
Zum Beispiel mit Copilot-Buggen,
zahlen sie zwischen 250 und 30.000 Dollar.
Und für Azure-Buggen, Microsofts Cloud-Appliance,
zahlen sie 1250 Dollar bis zu 60.000 Dollar.
Und manchmal mehr,
aufgrund der sehr, sehr schweren Bugs.
Bug-Bounties sind eine schwierige Sache zu navigieren.
Und die, wirklich die Krüge dieses gesamten Systems,
basieren auf der Firma und der Person, die den Bericht erhält,
folgendes Honor System.
Der Forscher muss Microsoft genug Beweise haben,
eines echten Sicherheitsproblems, wenn sie es berichten,
zumindest genug in den meisten Fällen,
damit Microsoft das Problem wiederherstellen kann und nicht nur sagt,
Oh, das funktioniert auf meiner Maschine, ich kann kein Problem herstellen.
Deshalb existiert es nicht.
And then, when the company can confirm the problem, they have to actually cough up the dough that they say they would for this researcher responsibly disclosing the information to them first and giving them time to fix it before they go and write a blog post and post a proof of concept onto GitHub.
So sollte es zumindest laufen, ja.
Dass nicht die gesamte Welt darüber Bescheid weiß, bevor es gefixt ist.
In der Regel klappt das ja eigentlich auch ganz gut, zumindest bei den letzten paar Linux-Körnel-Sicherheitlücken hat es ja ganz gut geklappt, aber hat es ja auch nicht gut geklappt.
Und idealerweise sollten sie auch mit dem Forscher arbeiten, während der Patch-Phase, um sicherzustellen, dass der Bug voll fixiert ist, weil natürlich ihr internes Sicherheits-Team das Problem nicht erfüllt hat.
Aber laut diesem Hacker-Blog-Post hat Microsoft nicht ihre...
I was not bluffing Microsoft and I'm doing it again, okay?
Blue Hammer.
I'm not explaining how this works.
Okay, der Typ kommt sich ein bisschen verarscht vor von Microsoft.
Wahrscheinlich auch berechtigterweise.
Hast du schon mal Schwachstellen gefunden und gemeldet?
Ja, einmal.
aber nicht bei Microsoft
ich hab mal eine Sicherheits
eine Schwachstelle
gemeldet an einen Hersteller von
Überwachungskameras
und ich hab
ein unlisted
GitHub
ein Gist erstellt
auf GitHub unlisted
und hab denen das zugeschickt
hier findet ihr quasi die ganzen
Details zu,
wie das geht.
Also im Prinzip konntest du den
Videostream von der Kamera
abrufen und hast das Root-Passwort von der Kamera
rausbekommen mit einem Curl-Aufruf
auf die richtige URL.
Was halt echt irgendwie schon
peinlich ist, ja.
Root-Passwort und Stream ohne
Passwort. Naja, beziehungsweise du konntest
mit einem Curl-Aufruf das Root-Passwort rauskriegen,
mit dem Root-Passwort konntest du dann den Stream angucken.
So, und das erste, was sie geschrieben haben, ist, ach, installieren Sie doch die neuesten Sicherheitsupdates und nehmen Sie bitte, ähm, diese Sache von GitHub runter. Das war das erste Problem, was sie hatten, dass ich irgendwas auf GitHub anlistet hatte. Nicht irgendwie, oh Mist, da könnte ja was dran sein. Ne, ne, installieren Sie mal Updates und nehmen Sie das von GitHub runter. Das war das erste Problem, was sie hatten.
und dann habe ich ihn nochmal
geantwortet und gesagt, ey, Leute,
Updates ist
das Neueste und wie gesagt,
das, was ich euch gezeigt habe, das ist jetzt
nichts irgendwie kompliziertes
oder so, du kannst einen Curl aufrufen
und dann bin ich da wahrscheinlich auch mal zu einem echten
Mensch durchgekommen, der das gelesen hat und hat gesagt,
ups,
ist ja doch ein Problem
und man muss ihn zugute
halten, ich habe das auch, ich habe das nicht
auch irgendwie öffentlich
geschaltet den Gist oder so.
Die haben gesagt, sie brauchen ein bisschen für,
bis das gepatcht ist.
Und nach, ich hab das dann schon wieder vergessen,
nach irgendwann einem halben
Jahr oder so, haben die mir
dann noch eine Mail geschrieben, die neueste Version
hätte jetzt das Problem behoben.
Also das war auch
semi-schnell.
Also müssen wir mal überlegen,
einfach einen Curl aufrufen, ohne irgendwas
kriegst du das Root-Passwort raus,
ist halt schon für eine Überwachungskamera auch doof.
Das ist aber das einzige Mal, wo ich mich jetzt dran erinnern kann, war wahrscheinlich auch das einzige Mal, wo ich irgendwas gefunden habe, was ich so kritisch eingestuft hätte, dass ich es gemeldet habe.
Ja, ansonsten nö, nix.
Ich würde jetzt gerne mal kurz gucken hier, GitHub, GitHub, Blue Hammer, wir gucken uns das mal kurz an.
Die Nudel.
Kann ich mich besser konzentrieren.
Blue Hammer.
Nightmare Clips Blue Hammer.
Ob wir da was...
Moment, haben die das geblockt?
Ne.
Äh.
Chat?
Haben die das...
Haben die das Repo...
Könnt ihr mal probieren, falls ihr eingeloggt seid bei GitHub, ob ihr das aufmachen könnt?
Haben die das irgendwie geblockt? Kann das sein?
Ah.
Ah ja.
Das ist ja schon einen Monat alt.
Na gut, dann gucken wir uns das Video doch mal fertig an.
Die Cloud-Files-API und opportunistische Locken, um eine Zeitverwaltung zu einer Zeitverwaltung zu verhindern,
Race Condition. The exploit
does not require kernel bugs,
memory corruption or admin
privileges. That's the whole point of using
it, is to get admin privileges.
And when successful, it leaks
the Security Account Manager database
Dürfte man dieses Exploit jetzt schon lokal
testen oder kommst du dafür schon in IKDAS?
Darfst du. Du darfst auf deiner Kiste erstmal
machen, was du willst.
Through a VSS Snapshot, it extracts
the NTLM Password Hashes,
takes over a local administrator
und dann eine System-Level-Schale spawnen.
Sie restauriert auch den originalen Passwort-Hash nachher, um Detektion zu vermeiden.
Red Sun verwendet einen Logik-Fraud in Windows Defenders File Remediation Path,
der einen Standard-User ermöglicht, Defenders eigenes Restore-Write in den System32-File zu redirektieren.
Wenn Defender ein Cloud-Tagged-Malicious-File detektiert,
schreibt es das File zurück in seine originalen Detektions-Path,
Moment.
Ich muss gerade mal lesen.
Aha.
Also wenn
Wenn Windows Defender
Eine verdächtige Datei gefunden hat
Die einen Cloud Tag hat
Was auch immer das genau bedeutet
Wahrscheinlich wenn man es gedownloadet hat
Oder sowas
Dann
Schreibt sie Datei
Trotzdem wieder zurück an die Stelle
Wo sie ursprünglich
Gelegen hat
was irgendwie keinen Sinn macht, weil der hat ja erkannt, dass das verdächtig ist.
So, und das nutzt er irgendwie aus.
...validating whether that path has been replaced with a junction point.
And then, just when you have a malicious file, it writes the file back to its original detection path
without validating whether that path has been replaced with a junction point.
Ah!
Das File wird detected.
Dann ändert der irgendwie was an der Location, wo das File war.
Windows Defender versucht die Datei wieder dahin zurückzuschreiben und dann gibt es Probleme.
We're talking about a BitLocker Bypass and another local privilege escalation primitive released publicly in the same scorched earth style.
So the Yellow Key Zero Day bypasses BitLocker encryption on Windows 11 and Windows Server 2022 and 2025.
The exploit abuses a debugging feature.
Lass mal kurz lesen.
I just reverse engineered Yellow Key BitLocker Bypass.
Microsoft-Chip-Code
that checks for a flag called
Fail-Relog in every
Windows 11 Recovery Image.
Aha. Okay.
Wenn das quasi true ist...
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Warum kann
ein Recovery
Image
mein BitLocker
Drive
anlocken, ohne dass ich ein Passwort eingeben muss.
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
TPM, ja okay, mal komplett für den Arsch, Alter.
Ich weiß schon, warum ich Windows Defender nicht verwende, ähm, warum ich BitLocker nicht verwende.
Ja, mein Argument dafür, alle Festplatten immer voll zu verschlüsseln, ist ja, also eines der Argumente dafür ist ja, dass du auch eine kaputte Festplatte einfach in den Müll schmeißen kannst.
Und niemand kommt mehr an eure Daten dran.
Ja, es ist, ich gebe zu, es ist eine theoretische Sache. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand eure Festplatte aus dem Müll fischt, um eure, keine Ahnung, MRT-Bilder oder so sich anzugucken, ist nur relativ gering.
Ja, aber es geht ja um die theoretische Möglichkeit und ich wette mit euch, jeder hat Sachen auf seinem Rechner von irgendwelchen privaten Bildern bis medizinische Sachen, whatever.
ja oder seine seine anime collection keine ahnung wo er nicht unbedingt will dass die jemand anderes
sehen kann und deswegen ist einfach von standardmäßig baumann aus drauf kopiert voll
verschlüsselt der beste ansatz selbst wenn die festplatte nicht mehr komplett lesbar ist so dass
man sie nicht mehr irgendwie überschreiben kann bevor man sie wegschmeißen kannst ja einfach sicher
sein es kann damit keiner was anfangen ja du musst dir nicht zerstören und danach und so also ich
Ich finde es einfach praktisch, wenn die Festplatte voll verschlüsselt ist.
So und da schmeißt du deinen Rechner weg, wie das ja viele machen.
Oder verkaufen ihren Rechner bei Ebay.
Whatever.
Die Oma verkauft ihren alten Rechner bei Ebay.
Und.
Jetzt kann man ohne das Passwort einfach die Disk entsperren.
Was ist das?
Warum ist das überhaupt?
Warum existiert sowas überhaupt?
Das widerspricht doch allen Sicherheitsempfinden, dass sowas überhaupt gibt.
gut ich weiß warum es das gibt das ist weil die übliche geschichte in der firma zum beispiel ja
irgendjemand vergisst sein passwort und hat wichtige daten noch auf dem laptop und sagt
dann könnte mir mal helfen das ganze zu restaurieren und ja das können ihm dann
helfen das zu restaurieren mit irgendwelchen keys die sie gebackup haben oder recovery sachen und
sowas und ja wahrscheinlich die nsa auch aber weil aus diesem gedanken ist man so was wahrscheinlich
überhaupt erst eingebaut bei bitlocker gibt es bei default kein passwort wird einfach im tpm
gespeichert der entweder in den cpu liegt oder einem extra chip auf mainboard dann kann ja aber
Aber allein schon, das ist doch für einen Arsch.
Das heißt, wenn jemand wirklich Zugriff auf meinen Rechner hat, kann er das entschlüsseln.
Das ist in der Regel kein Problem.
Die meisten Leute von uns werden jetzt nicht irgendwas haben, wo die NSA im Haus steht.
Oder wie heißt das Gegenstück von der NSA?
Äh, Spons.
Die meisten Leute werden nichts haben, warum das so sein könnte.
Aber allein schon die Möglichkeit dahinter, dass du sagen könntest, ey, wer Zugriff auf den Rechner hat, hat Zugriff auf alle Daten, der BND, ja, ist doch schon mal für den Arsch.
Weil, weil, passt mal auf, passt mal auf, Beispiel, Beispiel, ja.
Stellt euch mal vor
Ihr habt euren Rechner
Fröhliche Musik zu einem unangenehmen Thema
Stellt euch mal vor
Ihr habt euren Laptop
Ihr fliegt damit
In irgendwie eines der Länder
Die es mit Menschenrechten
Und Körperverletzungen
Und allem möglichen nicht so genau nehmen
Sucht euch eins aus
Oder ihr wollt da wieder ausreisen
oder was auch immer. Ihr landet dann dort bei der Polizei
am Flughafen, die kontrolliert euch
und sagen dann zu euch, ey,
oder die USA, whatever,
sucht euch ein Land aus. Die sagen dann zu euch,
ey, guck mal, du hast dein Laptop dabei,
wir wollen wissen, was da drauf ist.
Dann sagst du, nee.
Dann sagen die, doch.
Dann sagst du, ja, dann
dann sagen die, ja, dann
konfiszieren wir halt dein Laptop
und du gibst uns das Passwort.
Und dann sagst du nee.
So, und der nächste Schritt ist dann je nach Land unterschiedlich.
Wenn es Länder sind, die komplett auf Menschenrechte und Folter und sowas scheißen,
die vielleicht auch nicht so das krasse technische Know-how haben,
dann hauen die dir einfach so lange auf die Fresse,
bis du ihnen freiwillig das Passwort gibst.
Oder aber, wenn sie das technische Know-how haben,
dann verwenden sie jetzt diese
Entschlüsselung mit BitLocker
aber allein schon, dass diese Möglichkeit
existiert, ohne Passwort
wenn man den Rechner hat
das auszulesen, ist doch voll für den Arsch
die können auch beides machen, ja klar
die können auch beides machen
einfach linux mit verschlüsseln ist ein fix ja wäre krippte unter windows geht genauso
es muss ja noch nicht mal eine vollverschlüsselung sein ja wenn man einfach nur sagt man möchte also
man vollverschlüsselung ist halt easy du musst ja keine gedanken zu machen über über deine du
Du kannst da einfach sensible Daten drauf speichern und weißt, okay, kommt keiner dran.
Solange der Rechner nicht angeschaltet und unlockt ist.
Aber selbst wenn nicht, man kann ja auch einfach sich einen VeraCrypt Container oder sowas anlegen.
Das geht ja auch.
Und dann irgendwie seine medizinischen Sachen oder was auch immer man hat,
was man für schützenswert hält, da drin speichern.
Es geht ja alles.
geht ja alles. Aber Bitlocker,
also,
ich fühle mich gerade wieder bestätigt,
übrigens hier, guck mal, ob das der
Bitlocker-Fix ist.
Ich fühle mich gerade wieder bestätigt,
dass ich von Anfang an gesagt habe, Bitlocker ist Schrott.
Das verwende ich nicht.
Wera-Crypt mit verstecktem OS.
Das geht auch. Das ist natürlich
die Premium-Variante. Das stimmt.
Da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht. Habe ich auch nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich benutze das eigentlich hauptsächlich zu dem Grund, ich will einfach meine Platte, meine Festplatte auch in den Müll schmeißen können, ohne mir Gedanken machen zu müssen, dass mir irgendjemand da auf mein Zeug zugreift kann, was da drauf war.
Beziehungsweise immer noch drauf ist in verschlüsselter Form.
Und deswegen habe ich halt bei mir alles standardmäßig voll verschlüsselt und gut ist.
Mit verstecktem OS ist natürlich nochmal Next Level.
Da kannst du sogar sagen, ich gebe euch das Passwort und dann landest du auf einem OS, wo halt nichts drauf ist.
Und...
Nass und das einfach verschlüsseln.
Naja, ist die Frage, wie du den Zugriff da drauf geschützt hast.
Wenn die das Nass einfach mitnehmen, ohne dass sie es ausschalten, ist es ja in der Regel entschlüsselt, weil das nur zu Bootzeiten...
Zu Bootzeiten!
quasi entschlüsselt wird.
Für sowas eignen sich dann
Container zum Beispiel, ja?
Die musst du dann wirklich jedes Mal mounten hier,
beispielsweise bei Veracrypt,
würdest du die mounten und dann kannst du aufs Nastic.
Es gibt verschiedene Varianten, man muss es aber nicht übertreiben.
Ja, aber
weil du es hier sagst,
Veracrypt mit verstecktem OS ist tatsächlich
bei sowas die
Premium-Lösung.
Das wurde ja unter anderem auch dafür
entwickelt für zum Beispiel
Geheimdienstmitarbeiter oder sowas.
die vielleicht enttarnt werden und dann sagen, ja okay, ich gebe euch das Passwort, guckt auf meinen Laptop drauf, da ist nichts.
Und die gucken sich das auf dem Laptop an und finden auch nichts.
Und du hast aber in Wirklichkeit quasi ein encryptetes, verstecktes OS noch da drauf, wo dann deine Geheimdienstsachen drauf liegen.
Und das kannst du nicht erkennen.
Analyse der Festplatte. Es sieht komplett random aus. Das ist ja gerade der Witz.
also du kannst es quasi abstreiten ohne anhaltspunkte dafür dass es das gibt
weil ansonsten wenn man da einfach nachgucken könnte und jeder sehen würde
ach guck mal da ist ein verstecktes us könnten ja trotzdem sagen ja gut dann
haben wir so lange aufs maul bis ins passwort dafür gibt aber so kann zu
sagen er gibt es nicht guckt euch hier an muss halt ein geschulter
geheimdienstmitarbeiter sein da das gut der gut schauspielern kann und sagen ja
Guckt mal hier, ich habe doch nichts.
Hier habt ihr das Passwort, guckt es euch an.
Und dann in der Hoffnung, dass die nicht auf verstecktes OS kommen.
Ja, aber das ist die Premium-Variante.
Wer kommt mit verstecktem OS?
Und cleanem OS?
Wie wollen die ein NAS mitnehmen, ohne es vorher auszuschalten?
Steckt doch in der Steckdose.
Da gibt es Möglichkeiten.
Das zu überbrücken.
Die hatten zum Beispiel auch mal eine Weile, habe ich gelesen irgendwo, ja, die hatten zum Beispiel auch eine Weile mal so, so, so, ähm, USB-Mäuse, die Mausbewegungen simuliert haben, also, dass der Bildschirm schon noch nicht angeht und sowas.
Richtig, richtig, genau
Das ist ja das, was ich meine
Ob ich jetzt quasi meine Festplatte wegschmeiße
Weil sie nicht mehr richtig geht
Oder ich sie nicht mehr brauche
Keiner kommt an die Daten dran
Ob ich meinen Laptop verliere oder mir der geklaut wird
Keiner kommt dran
Deswegen ist es einfach beruhigend zu wissen
Ey, komm, egal
Wie hirnlos du mal bist
Oder wie kaputt die Hardware ist
und du schmeißt sie weg, das wird geklaut.
Es kommt halt keiner dran.
Und jeder, Leute, jeder hat bei sich auf dem Rechner irgendwas.
Es muss ja nichts Schlimmes sein.
Ich habe auch nichts Schlimmes bei mir auf dem Rechner.
Ja, aber ich habe zum Beispiel MRT-Bilder oder sowas,
wo man drauf sieht, dass ich nichts habe.
Aber solche Dinger, das will man einfach nicht,
dass man das sieht.
Oder sei es nur, vielleicht auch was,
wenn Leute
mit ihrer Freundin Nachrichten schreiben.
Ja, irgendwelche
schlüpfrigen Dinger.
Will man auch nicht, dass die
irgendjemand sieht.
Oder sowas, ja.
Oder Familienfotos
mit irgendwas.
Jeder hat Sachen drauf, wo man nicht will,
dass die von anderen
Leuten ausgelesen werden können.
Neueinrichten, dann verkaufen, geht schneller als überfüllen.
Ja, was machst du denn aber zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Festplatte hast?
Mir geht es jetzt nicht darum, wie realistisch dieses Szenario ist, sondern nur, dass es möglich ist.
Was machst du denn, wenn du eine Magnetfestplatte hast, so eine ganz klassische alte Festplatte,
unverschlüsselt, und die geht dir kaputt?
Wohlgemerkt, die geht dir nicht richtig kaputt
Die geht dir einfach nur so kaputt, dass du nicht mehr drankommst
Deine Daten sind höchstwahrscheinlich immer noch lesbar da drauf
Wie gesagt, ich weiß, dass es äußerst unrealistisch ist
Dass das Ding irgendjemand aus dem Müll klaut
Und dann den Aufwand treibt, es wieder herzustellen
Aber stell dir mal drauf, du hast da wirklich irgendwas drauf
Wo du dir ganz sicher sein willst, dass es keiner mehr auslesen kann
Ja und auch mit der Bohrmaschine, damit doktort man quasi um das Problem drumherum.
Ja, du könntest die Dinger zu Staub schreddern, da kann die auch keiner mehr auslesen.
Aber das ist ja letztendlich um das eigentliche Problem nur drumherum gedoktert, dass die Daten prinzipiell mal da drauf gespeichert waren im Klartext.
So, und wenn du sowas wie Lux, also es ist ja nicht Lux unter Linux oder VeraCrypt unter Windows verwendest, dann hast du die Probleme halt nicht.
Du musst dir keine Gedanken machen.
Aber wenn die Festplatte kaputt ist, kannst du die nicht einfach overwriten.
Vielleicht willst du die Festplatte ja auch verkaufen, anstatt in den Müll zu schmeißen und wegzuschmeißen.
Also, alles mögliche. Am besten ist, einfach standardmäßig die schützenswerten Daten, die man hat, zu verschlüsseln.
Und wie gesagt, ihr müsst jetzt gar nicht an irgendwelche schlimmen Sachen denken, ja?
Also, was weiß ich, wenn einer von euch jetzt irgendwie vorhat, boah, keine Ahnung, was gibt's denn da,
irgendwelche illegalen Waffen zu verkaufen im Darknet oder so, ja?
Das muss es ja nicht mal unbedingt sein. Ich hoffe, dass ihr das nicht vorhabt.
Wäre besser für euch, wenn ihr das nicht vorhabt, ja?
Aber es muss ja nicht gleich was richtig Illegales sein, ja?
Ihr müsst ja auch keine Anschläge planen oder sowas.
Es reicht ja schon, wenn dort irgendwelche Dinger drauf sind,
wo ihr halt einfach nicht wollt, dass es jemand sieht.
Sei es, bestes Beispiel ist, ihr habt irgendeine Geschlechtskrankheit, whatever, ja?
Wollt ihr wirklich, dass das potenziell jeder auslesen kann?
Gut.
Dann gucken wir jetzt das Video mal weiter.
Moment, Moment, jetzt habe ich aufgepasst, jetzt habe ich aufgepasst, Moment, das muss ich mir gerade nochmal gucken.
Okay, das ist das, wo ich gerade gesagt habe, ich wundere mich, dass es überhaupt geht, ja.
um den Drive für Testen zu entdecken, aber dann...
gesamte private Krankengeschichte, Kommunikation, Browserverlauf, whatever, was es alles gibt,
dass das dann zugreifbar ist, nur weil ihr irgendwie gesagt habt, jemand ist ein Pimmel
auf Twitter?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und allein schon das spricht dafür, seine Festplatten zu verschlüsseln.
So, jetzt gucken wir weiter.
Das ist jetzt wirklich ein halbwegs aktuelles Beispiel, wo man sieht, man muss kein Terrorist sein, dass man sich um sowas vielleicht Gedanken machen sollte.
Ich habe es immer noch nicht gecheckt.
Okay, okay.
Moment, was bin ich jetzt hier sehen?
Rack get value. Ist das Registry?
Microsoft Recovery Environment.
Fail Relog.
Okay, checks if fail relog is set to 1.
Skips Relog Entirely
Bitlocker Volume Stays Unencrypted
Moment, das heißt
Du musst einfach nur einmal F8 oder sowas drücken
Ins Recovery Image booten
Dann irgendwas machen
Und dann bleibt die Festplatte entsperrt
Oder wie
Als Nicht-ITler
was wäre da eine gute vorgehensweise zum verschlüsseln unter windows und dann
wenn es gibt es eigentlich nur das hier
unter windows gibt es eigentlich nur das hier
was du verwenden kannst dafür wie du es dann machst musste dir überlegen also du
kannst sagen verschlüsselt eine komplette festplatte komplett dann
musst du beim booten ein passwort eingeben wenn du das passwort nicht mehr weiß sind
deine daten weg das muss dir klar sein das kannst du nicht über bitlocker dann wieder
recover passwort weg daten weg dann musst du beim booten ein passwort eingeben und dein
komplettes system ist voll verschlüsselt das würde ich aber nicht unbedingt jedem empfehlen
das so zu machen, weil Windows-Updates können potenziell das kaputt machen
und dann muss man mit einem Recovery-Stick den VeraCrypt-Bootloader neu draufhauen.
Also es ist jetzt für nicht so IT-affine Leute vielleicht nicht unbedingt das Allerallerbeste,
VeraCrypt-Vollverschlüsselung zu machen.
Was du aber machen kannst ist, ich kann dir das sogar mal zeigen, wenn du willst.
sagen wir mal VeraCrypt auf.
So, VeraCrypt.
So schaut das aus.
Du kannst dir Dateien legen.
Du kannst jetzt sagen, hier
New Volumes, Create New Volume.
Dann sagst du hier
Create Encrypted File
Container.
Standard VeraCrypt Volume
Location.
Location lege ich jetzt hier auf dem Desktop.
Nenne ich jetzt hier
kegw.png oder sowas.
Vollkommen egal, wie das heißt.
Never save history, zack
We strongly recommend that you avoid file extensions
that are used for executables
Okay, okay
Wir nennen es
kekw.hc
oder was haben die gesagt?
Okay, so
Ist aber auch egal
Das geht nicht im Stream zu zeigen
Ach, ihr seht das nicht?
Boah, ist das next level, Alter
Das ist ja
voll high IQ
dass sie das nicht anzeigen.
Ha!
Okay, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Wir starten Windows einfach
in der VM. Easy.
Outplayed, würde ich sagen.
Habe ich hier irgendein Windows noch?
Ist das ein Windows?
POC Desktop? Nee.
Moment.
Wisst ihr was?
Wisst ihr was? Das machen wir jetzt schnell.
Musst du unter Optionen aktivieren?
Nee, ich installiere mir jetzt ein Windows.
Windows 11 nebenbei, während wir das Video fertig gucken.
Jetzt runterladen.
Äh, nein, nein, nein, nein.
ISO auswählen.
Jetzt runterladen.
Ich hoffe, das ist jetzt nicht in Deutsch.
Aber selbst wenn, juckt mich auch nicht.
bestätigen. Wählen Sie eine Sprache aus.
Englisch.
Jetzt runterladen.
Seht das jetzt?
Okay.
Ich zeige euch das gleich.
Okay, wir gucken das Video jetzt weiter
und dann zeige ich euch das.
Das ist so für Technik nicht affine,
finde ich, die beste Möglichkeit.
Sachen, die man selbst für schützenswert hält, zu verschlüsseln unter Windows.
Vielleicht ist das wirklich das NSA-Bagdor.
Was zum Teufel ist Green Plasma?
Schauen wir davon aus.
Ey, der Typ, der ist aber richtig, richtig krass dabei, oder?
Richtig high IQ Pfeifhead-Dude.
Der hat ja am Laufen Bandhauter hier Windows Exploits raus.
Big Brain.
High IQ.
Wie lange haben denn solche Lücken einen Lebenszyklus?
Und ist Microsoft gepatcht?
In der Regel.
Sie können nicht wirklich dein System beeinflussen, bis jemand bereits einen Art von Zugang dazu hat.
Normalerweise eine Art von Remote-Code-Execution.
Und dann fahren sie diese Skripte, um ihre Privilegien zum System zu erhöhen.
Und dann ist es auf die Rennen.
Sie haben auf dieser Stelle vollständig deinen Computer.
Und natürlich, Yellow Key ist ein Bitlocker-Bepasser, der physische Zugang zu deinem Computer braucht, um es zu brechen.
Also, wenn du wie so viele Leute these Tage, die einfach innerhalb ihres Hauses bleiben und nie Gras anstecken,
Ironically, you're maybe safer from this exploit than the people who go out with their laptops.
Now, as for the other exploits, Bluehammer was patched by Microsoft on April 14th, 2026,
which lends a little bit of credence to the researcher's story that Microsoft decided to screw them over
instead of actually pay them a bug bounty, assuming that this researcher truly was the first person to report the problem.
Ich meine, ich glaube, es gibt eine Chance, dass jemand anderes es veröffentlicht hat und Microsoft sie bezahlt hat.
Wir haben wirklich nur einen Teil der Gespräche oder einen Teil des Angriffs hier, der von den Hackern auf dem Blog postet.
Und dieser Forscher hat auch geplant, dass die Red Sun-Verletzung silenziert gepatcht wurde.
Also das ist etwas, was wir nicht bekommen haben.
Wir haben überhaupt keine Erklärung bekommen.
Es gab kein CVE, nichts.
Nur, dass es nicht mehr funktioniert.
Es scheint aber, dass es keine aktuellen Verbesserungen für Green Plasma und Yellow Key gibt.
Also seid sehr vorsichtig mit den Filen, die ihr auf eurer Maschine downloadet und ausübt,
denn ihr wisst nie, wann ihr von einem Scriptkiddy kompromisiert wird,
mit einem Zero-Day-Malware, das von einem Sicherheitsforscher veröffentlicht wurde,
das von einer tech-Firmenkommunikation von einem Trillionen Dollar verfehlt wurde.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, dann lasst ein Like da und teilt es mit dem Algorithmus.
Und schaut auch meine Online-Store base.win, wo ihr meine tollen Merch oder Accessoires kaufen könnt,
oder Accessories für Ihr Handy oder Laptop.
10% Storewide Discount und Pay-Per-Mail-Rate.
macht das ist super easy
Windows
Zack
Nur kurz escape escape escape escape drücken und wir müssen auf booten von ach
cd ist nicht
connected
Escape escape escape escape wir wollen booten
Vom cd
es soll jetzt zwei minuten
windows installieren ohne mailadresse weil ich installiere windows
professional ist doch eigentlich gar kein ding mehr oder da geht das da ging
das doch ohne probleme language install englisch englisch ja ja wunderbar
das ist das was wir hier machen stellen wir auf german um install windows
everything include product key haben wir nicht genau ich kann wieder domain joinen das werde
ich auch machen also einfach sagen ich join per domain und da um dann nicht per domain zu joinen
Oh, meine Güte.
Windows, Windows, nerv nicht rum.
Wie ging das jetzt hier nochmal?
TPM?
Must be in UEFI.
Okay.
Ist doch in UEFI.
Hä?
Wo ist das Problem jetzt?
Muss ich...
Okay.
Keine Ahnung.
New Virtual Machine.
Custom.
Ja.
Windows.
ganz toll ja ja in krypto massive passwort kommt nie einer drauf
es ließ 8 charakter das ist also allein schon eine win of fucking windows vm
anzulegen ist ja mittlerweile abfuck hoch 10 16 gig not next next next next
Next, next, next.
Okay, jetzt müsste aber eins funktionieren.
Meine Güte, was sagt der?
Schauen wir mal, ob Secure Boot an sein muss.
Glaube ich nicht.
Glaube, das geht auch ohne.
Was?
Oh, Alter.
Das muss ich noch ausschalten,
sonst ist es super lahm.
Wo war das jetzt? Side Channel?
Ja, das muss weg. Geh weg.
Okay, jetzt aber.
Jetzt können wir wieder was installieren.
Ist TPM nicht genau dafür?
Nee.
Für BitLocker vielleicht,
aber für wer kommt nicht so englisch englisch german ja ich kriege machen war
PauseChamp
Hey, Moment, Moment
Noch, noch
Ah ja, okay, Funst Accept
Next
Install, jawoll
Nice
Meine Güte, ey
Allein schon die Installation von
Windows 11
Y-A-F-A-Q-10.
Und wisst ihr, was jetzt gleich kommt?
Wenn Windows 11 installiert ist,
dann kommt jetzt gleich
keine Telemetrie.
Nein, nein, nein. Basic.
Nein, nein. Basic. Basic. Nein, nein.
Okay.
So, was haben wir denn noch hier Schönes?
I've been playing...
Linux Experience. Two years later.
...
Ich bin seit fast 2 Jahren mit Linux unterwegs und ich habe nur ein paar Leute über das, wie unkompetent ich bin, verärgert.
Genau, Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows, habe ich gemerkt.
Ich finde, ich erkläre das, und das sagen wir mal so, zu 90% gilt das auch heutzutage noch.
Der Gaming-Part ist tatsächlich noch besser geworden als damals.
Allerdings die Probleme mit Anti-Cheat-Spielen und so bestehen natürlich immer noch.
Leute, sogar unter dem Video, was ich finde, was echt neutral gehalten ist
und auch eigentlich wenig Angriffsfläche bietet, ja.
sind die Leute hier teilweise
am Abgehen und
und flamen, ja.
Was ist mit dem Typ hier los?
Sie können nicht mal ihr Update-Verhalten
einstellen, dass es nicht automatisch
installiert wird und wollen dann auf Linux
wechseln. Hä?
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht,
was er will.
Der Videotitel löst auch schon was aus.
Ja, gut, das stimmt.
Da hast du recht.
Ich muss aber auch sagen, das ist Absicht.
Weil ihr wisst, Engagement ist wichtig für Videos.
Ich habe damit schon gerechnet, ja?
Mir war das schon klar.
Der Videotitel ist ein wenig Ragebait.
Das stimmt, ja.
Ich hab mich getäuscht
Okay
Dein Video ist 3 Jahre alt und Windows ist tot
Aha
Windows 11 ist die Katastrophe schlechthin
Ja das stimmt, das ist so
Ja und du hast dich getäuscht
Bei vielen, bei mir auch, ist das soweit
Linux ist soweit
Ja bis auf die Punkte, die ich damals angesprochen hab
Die immer noch gelten
Windows kann weg
trauen, das hier aufzumachen?
Fazit.
Oh, das sind eine halbe Stunde.
Das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken. Das ist zu lange.
Fazit.
Linux ist ein voller Punktzieg für...
Ach, der hat einfach nur gepostet,
um Werbung für sein Video zu machen. Sehe ich das richtig?
Alter, was für Soundqualität.
Da würde ich das als PDF
speichern.
PDF?
Headset lässt grüßen, äh.
Dann sage ich zum Beispiel hier
explodieren, explodieren.
Monka Sound.
So klang ich wahrscheinlich,
als ich CS, äh, CS
052 gespielt hab, über,
über, das war noch nicht mal
Teamspeak, Roger Wilko oder sowas.
Ich hatte damals
einen Microsoft Sidewinder Headset.
Das Ding hier.
Sidewinder Game Voice.
Hatte ich damals.
Hier, 2001 der Test.
Das klang ungefähr so von der Qualität her.
Hattest du das auch?
Das war vor die damalige Zeit eigentlich richtig cool, das Ding.
Aus heutiger Zeit wirkt das und war das auch echt billig und Plastik und sowas.
Aber für damals war das schon nice.
Das ist ein richtiger Plastikbomber, das Ding.
Was ich immer noch habe, dieses Ding hier
Dieses Ding habe ich immer noch
Als Verlängerung mit einem Mute-Button
Ja.
hattest du auch den passenden
Fanatic Headshot Controller dazu
ne ich wusste damals gar nicht
dass es den Fanatic Headshot Controller gibt
wer das nicht kennt hier
absolute
High-End-Gaming-Equipment.
Äh, hallo?
Windows ist fertig installiert, ja.
Äh.
Wer in Computerspielen die Nase vorn haben will,
braucht eine Top-Ausstattung.
Und da ist der Fanatec
Hatchet Controller genau das Richtige.
Das Set besteht aus einer Ultra...
Dieses Kabel, Alter!
Dieses Kabel!
Das sieht aus wie ein Laptop-Schloss, Mann!
...Season-Gamer-Maus und einem Highspeed-Pad.
Zusammen ein unschlagbares Team.
Die Maus ist super ergonomisch
und lässt sich an jede Handform anpassen.
Das sorgt auch in langen Gamer-Sessions
für ermüdungsfreies Spielen.
Sechs Maus-Buttons und ein 5-Wege-Steuerrad
sorgen dafür, dass Sie Ihre Spielfigur
auch in heißen Gefechten im Griff haben. Die Plasma-Gleit-Maus-Füße sorgen zusammen mit dem
Highspeed-Pad für minimale Haft. Wisst ihr, das ist so was, das bestellt die Oma für den Enkel beim
Teleshopping und denkt sich, die hat jetzt was richtig geiles bestellt. Gleitreibung für schnelles,
präzises Zielen im Spiel. Das leichte Kabel kommt ihnen dabei garantiert nicht in die Quere. Dafür
sorgt die clevere Kabelführung. Fetzige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen Farben,
Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz machen das Spiel noch rasanter. Profigamer sind begeistert von
den Programmiermöglichkeiten für Maus und Tastatur, selbst während des Spiels. Auch
Makros lassen sich problemlos einsetzen. Damit sind sie bei Flugsimulationen, Rennspielen und
anderen Games der King. Der Fnatic Headshot Controller ist das ultimative Set für Gamer
und wetten, dass er auch als Geschenk gut ankommt.
Probieren Sie es aus.
Ich sage, das ist für die Omas, die ihren Enkeln was kaufen wollen.
Und Leute, ich würde sagen, direkt bestellen, oder?
Ist das real?
Ja, das ist 13 Jahre alt.
Da gab es noch kein KI.
Okay, Windows 11 ist fertig.
Jetzt müssen wir mal wieder...
Which country...
Übrigens, man kann hier...
By the way, ne?
Man kann hier nicht G drücken für Germany oder so.
Das geht nicht.
Man muss hier wirklich runterscrollen,
bis man irgendwann Germany gefunden hat.
Das ist so unglaublich schlecht gemacht.
Ja, wer will in den Games nicht mal der King sein?
Nein? Wie kommt ihr auf die Idee, dass ich in Germany nicht German Input haben will? Skip. So, jetzt kommt die erstmal die Abwählorgie. Nein, nein, Basic, Basic, nein.
Windows, nerv nicht rum
Ich lebe nur auf Twitter in Andorra
Leider interessiert das Twitter nicht mehr
Und ich krieg trotzdem fast
Nur noch deutsche Trends
Good things come your way, Adam
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ich das Windows Setup massiv kacke finde?
Wie scheiße ist denn dieser Installer? Der ist richtig scheiße.
Skip your device. KW-LUL-HD heißt das Ding jetzt. Next.
So muss das heißen. So und nicht anders.
Just a moment.
Achso, Reboot natürlich, was sonst
Du wartest auf den Tag, wo die diese Sachen tauschen
Und man aus Reflex immer das falsche auswählt
Okay, das Gute ist, ich installiere Windows so selten
Ich habe auf der Arbeit glücklicherweise natürlich auch nichts mit Windows-Administration am Hut
dass ich keinen Reflex habe, was Windows Installer angeht.
So, Chat, jetzt müsst ihr mir helfen.
Was muss ich machen,
dass ich in eine Domain joinen kann?
Wie geht das jetzt nochmal?
Setup for work?
Sign in options?
Domain join.
Enter your name.
Lul.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Kommt keiner drauf.
Top Secret.
Kann man...
Okay.
1.
2.
3.
Ja, in meiner Kindheit haben die mich immer 3 genannt.
Nein.
Basic.
So dumm, Alter.
Bei Personal Use wird das...
Ich glaube nicht mehr das.
Ich glaube, da wird das nicht mehr vorgeschlagen.
Früher musstest du F10 drücken und dann irgendwie was...
OOB Experience oder irgendwie sowas.
Oh, was ist das?
Ernsthaft?
Wie alt ist denn das ISO?
Ich habe das ISO gerade von der Webseite runtergeladen.
Update later.
Wird doch egal.
Ja, ja.
Hallo.
Früher kam es dann, hi,
I'm Cortana.
Als sich da noch jemand dran erinnert.
Ja, musste man erst mal muten, genau.
auf windows mach hin so viel kannst du doch gar nicht machen beim installieren
ich töne auch nicht den pc auf keine sorge microsoft
ISOs sind meistens 1-2 Monate
wirklich?
Also sogar richtig kleine
Linux-Distros
kriegen das auf die Reihe.
Okay, nicht unbedingt jede.
Es gibt welche, die haben auch richtig alte ISOs.
Aber zumindest,
sagen wir mal,
zumindest die großen Linux-Distributionen
kriegen das hin. Du kriegst einen Daily Debian,
einen Daily Ubuntu, einen Daily Fedora wahrscheinlich auch, einen Daily Alma Linux.
Okay, da sind wir.
Jetzt müssen wir erst nochmal sagen, dass ich das überhaupt richtig höre.
Install VM Tools.
VM Tools.
Autorun oder was muss man jetzt machen?
Nee, äh, äh, äh.
Run, Setup, Exe.
Yes.
So und danach sollten wir Fullscreen gehen können.
Und dann kann ich euch das mit Vergo Crypt zeigen.
Luku moin.
So wir können schon nochmal Chrome installieren, weil es das erste ist oder Firefox, weil es
das erste ist was ich mit Edge mache.
Wow.
Wisst ihr was? Ich mute das mal.
Das ist einfach nur nervig.
Okay, finish. Yes, reboot.
Excellent. Gut, fullscreen.
Auf geht's. Wie nicht edged?
Äh.
Winged Vera Crypt.
Tatsächlich. Das könnten wir auch machen.
Das machen wir jetzt. Wir installieren das jetzt über Winged.
Ne, wir machen das nicht über Winged.
Ich wollte es ja den Leuten zeigen,
die nicht so technisch versiert sind.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Wingate da das Richtige ist.
Wir laden das, wie das
alle so machen, über die Webseite runter.
Nein, du sollst nicht updaten. Ich hab doch gesagt, update later.
Warum, warum
updatet der jetzt? Der Kack-Noob,
Mann.
Der soll nicht updaten. Ich hab ihm doch eben gesagt,
update later.
nachher muss ich auch updaten hier
guck der nervt schon
und wenn ich jetzt hier auf shutdown gehe
oh oh oh Leute ich darf noch shutdownen ohne zu updaten
heute Nudeln mit Lachs
äh warte mal warte mal
was gibt es denn heute
ne heute kein Nudeln mit Lachs
heute gibt es Suppe
Kartoffel
Möhren
Suppe mit bisschen Sahne
drin das liegt daran
Eigentlich hätte es heute höchstwahrscheinlich Nudeln mit Lachs gegeben
Aber meine Mutter hat das gekocht
Und der war es gestern schlecht
Und er hat gesagt, sie brauchen ein bisschen was leichtes für den Magen
Deswegen gibt es jetzt nur Kartoffel und Karottensuppe
Ich schmeiß mir da aber
Oder dabei putter ich wahrscheinlich wieder so eine halbe Packung Toastbrot
Und dann bin ich auch satt
Digga, warum tust du dir das an mit Windows?
Weil ich was zeigen will unter Windows.
Sonst würde ich mir das auch nicht antun.
So, zack.
Äh, äh.
Was?
Oh Gott. Alter.
Fuck mich nicht ab.
Okay.
Chrome Download.
Kann ich das nicht in Englisch installieren?
Egal. Hauptsache was anderes
als Internet Explorer.
Wann programmier ich
mit Word als IDE?
Wir machen Raytracing in Excel demnächst.
Kennt ihr das?
Raytracing in Excel?
Da hat jemand was programmiert für.
der hat, weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich
mit Visual Basic oder so
irgendwie in Excel
programmiert, dass das Kugeln
und
Würfel raytracen kann.
Abgemeldet bleiben.
Dr. Go, okay.
Als Standard
festlegen.
Okay, und jetzt...
Oh, wie schnell ab.
U-Block.
So, wir müssen jetzt erstmal die Basics
der Basics installieren, ja.
Immer gucken, ob es der richtige ist.
Jawohl, sonst wird man gebatet
und kommt auf falsche.
Erweiterung hinzufügen.
Oh Mist, ich glaube ich hab...
Kann das sein, dass ich...
Ah ne.
Hui.
schon gedacht, ich habe ein bisschen zu früh
geschlossen. Okay, wunderbar. Also,
Veracrypt. Jetzt, das was ich dir zeige. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob derjenige, der gefragt hat, noch da ist.
Also, Veracrypt.
Veracrypt
I.O.?
Moment.
Veracrypt hatte doch
immer eine französische Webseite.
Nicht
.io?
Seit wann ist es veracrypt.io?
Was ist da los?
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, veracrypt ist irgendwas mit FR früher.
Interesting.
Dann gehen wir mal auf GitHub.
Können wir da auch das Neueste runterladen?
Guck mal, es gibt sogar eine neue Beta schon
Wen zähle ich als das neueste Beta-Version?
Ist egal, das was ich euch zeige geht bei allen Versionen gleich
Äh, Assets?
Äh
Sehe ich das richtig? Das gibt es gar nicht für Windows?
Moment, bin ich blind?
Es gibt keine Windows-Version zum Download, nur eine Mac-Version?
Bei der Beta-Version, was ist das denn?
Okay, aber hier gibt es die Windows-Version.
Die letzte Stable-Version gibt es auch für Windows.
Was bescheuert ist, weil es eigentlich so gut nur wie Windows-Leute verwenden.
Muss man das jetzt irgendwie verstehen?
Hier, so, da, zack.
Also, VeraCrypt runterladen, installieren
Scheint mir Windows
So beim richtigen Release gebaut
Ja, ja
Okay, jetzt kann ich das zeigen
Also wie gesagt, Vollverschlüsselung ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt
Das Sinnvollste, was ihr machen könnt, aber
Wenn ihr doch schützenswerte Daten habt
Dann installiert euch VeraCrypt
Macht Veracrypt auf und jetzt könnt ihr hier sagen
Create new volume
So
Encrypted file container, ihr wollt keine
System partition encrypten oder so, create
Encrypted file container
Standard Veracrypt volume, dann wo ihr das hin
Speichern wollt, ist egal, ich speichere jetzt mal auf dem Desktop
Kekkel.hc
So, next
Algorithmus könnt ihr alles standard lassen, next
Wie groß die Datei
Sein soll, ich mache jetzt mal
10 Gig, weil ich habe ja nur 38
ich gehe noch frei auf meiner vm so next passwort jetzt und das ist das wichtige jetzt müsst ihr
euch ein gutes sicheres passwort ausdenken aber eins was ihr euch auch merken könnt weil wie
gesagt daten passwort weg daten weg das ist nicht wie bei bit locker so was was ich ganz gerne habe
bei Passwörtern ist.
Einfache, aber möglichst
lange Passwörter.
Also wir könnten
zum Beispiel, ihr könntet jetzt zum Beispiel so was
machen.
Wenn die Systemplatte
verschüsselt ist, kannst du keine Funktionsupgrades
mehr machen. Doch.
Wobei, du hast recht.
Du hast recht. Manchmal funktioniert es nicht.
Das ist richtig. Also
das letzte Mal gab es Probleme bei
H2, glaube ich.
gab es probleme beim update deswegen wie gesagt ich würde auch meine festplatte wenn man gerade
wenn man technisch nicht so versiert ist würde ich keine festplatten vollverschlüsselung machen
weil windows updates können das auch mal kaputt machen dann musst du von einem usb stick den
werk und bootloader ist würde ich nicht unbedingt machen aber wenn man einfach nur seine seine
medizinischen Diagnosen
oder sonstige Sachen
da speichern will, dann
hier so ein Container.
Ja. Laptop würde ich
trotzdem voll verschlüsseln, ja.
Okay, ja, also ihr könnt jetzt zum Beispiel
sowas machen wie, man kann das Passwort
nicht anzeigen, ich zeig...
Oh, dieser Dreck, Mann!
Kann sich das mal ver... Egal.
Egal.
Ich bin in Pochmurni.
Wo ist das denn?
Ja, man könnte jetzt zum Beispiel ein Passwort machen hier.
Der Twitch-Chat ist Poggers.
So, das ist jetzt mein Passwort.
Oder der Twitch-Chat ist heute Poggers.
So, realistisch betrachtet hat keiner eine Chance, dieses Passwort irgendwie zu erraten.
Ja, jetzt kommen Leute an.
Ah, Wörterbuch, Wörterbuch.
Du hast so viele Wörter und so viele mögliche Kombinationen, das ist unmöglich, das in annehmbarer Zeit zu knacken.
So, das ist Passwort jetzt, was wir haben. Der Twitch-Chat ist heute Poggers.
Nennen wir das mal. Achso, Display-Passwort können wir machen.
PIM kann man auch machen. PIM ist diese Geschichte mit wie oft das Passwort rotiert wird, bevor es dann wirklich...
Das lassen wir jetzt mal weg. Display-Passwort, jawohl, yes.
Use Large Files kann man machen, wenn man
Dateien größer als
4 GB speichern will,
kann man anmachen, ist okay.
Filesystem kann man hier alles default lassen.
Jetzt muss man ein bisschen seine Maus hier drin rum
rödeln lassen, dass der
Randomness sammeln kann.
Und dann sagst du Format.
Format.
Und dann richtet er den Container ein.
bei der sprich dagegen sensible daten in einem passwort geschützten archiv zu packen da sprechen
aus meiner sicht ein paar sachen dagegen erstens ist es ziemlich umständlich und das zweite ist
bist du dir sicher dass die die die encryption funktion und alles in deiner tipp oder in einem
compression programm wirklich sicherheitstechnisch einwandfrei implementiert ist bei vera club würde
ich mich da schon eher darauf verlassen das ding ist audited reviewed und von vielen leuten
verwendet für diesen zweck also würde ich dann der sache eher trauen so fertig so als habt ihr
jetzt habt ihr hier eine datei die von außen betrachtet komplett random aussieht also man
kann nicht darauf schließen was da drin ist so und jetzt geht er hierhin sagt man kann es man
kann es glaube ich mittlerweile einfach doppelt anklicken genau klickt ihr das klickt ihr euren
store doppelt an sagt wohin er den mountain wollt ja zum beispiel wollt ihr das jetzt nach
f doppelpunkt mountain sagt man fertig das müsst ihr euer passwort eingeben wie gesagt passwort
weg daten weg gibt es noch klar kennt jemand noch das ist an die oldschool
leute kennt noch jemand win ace
ich fand mich damals richtig geil hacker mann zu zeiten wo ich linux
distributionen per torrent noch runtergeladen habe da haben die coolen
leute wenn es anstatt winter verwendet so jetzt geben wir hier unser passwort
ein dass da falls ihr irgendwelche speziellen
dingen hat wie pimp und sonst was dann klickt das an haben wir jetzt aber nicht
kopiert unser passwort da rein und jetzt sagt ja einfach nur okay mountain und
jetzt habt ihr unter f doppelpunkt ein eigenes laufwerk und hier könnt ihr jetzt machen was
ihr wollt drin letztendlich unter der haube lang landet das alles in dieser datei hat quasi diese
datei als eigenes laufwerk gemontet so ihr könnt ihr jetzt könnt ihr machen was ihr wollt ja hier
ordner erstellen drin das ein erstellen blub da hier top secret kram reinschreiben sagt speichern
wunderbar und wenn er fertig seid wenn er fertig seid dann sagt er einfach hier an ihr geht nicht
hier sagt er hier an mount und jetzt habt ihr nur eine datei hier liegen die nur noch ihr mit
eurem passwort wieder neu mountain könnt und auf den inhalt zugreifen können nur dann wenn das
passwort weg ist dann sind die dateien weg es sei denn ihr könnt das passwort brutforsten ja und
Und das ist eine ganz einfache Variante, aus eurer Sicht schützenswerten Dateien verschlüsselt bei euch abzulegen.
Und aus meiner Sicht für Windows auch die beste.
Ja, und das Ding muss doch nicht mal .hc oder irgendwie sowas heißen.
Dadurch, dass das Ding keine History speichert, wenn ihr jetzt neu startet, Vera Crypt, dann merkt sich das auch nicht, was ihr gemountet habt.
Also wenn dieses Ding hier jetzt nicht .hc heißt, wie kann man bei Windows überhaupt, wie kann man bei Windows das einblenden, dass man Dateiendungen angezeigt kriegt?
Chatgear, weiß das jemand? View, oder? View? Show? Teilname Extensions, genau.
Ja, also ihr könntet jetzt auch sagen, das Ding heißt .mp4, okay?
So.
Das ist egal, das muss nicht die Endung haben.
Ihr müsst nur wissen, wo die Datei liegt und welche es ist.
Select File, Desktop, Kekkel.mp4, Mounten.
Dann schreibt ihr hier unser Passwort rein, zack.
Und die Datei ist gemountet in F-Doppelpunkt.
und die datei selbst ist komplett random also wenn man die jetzt öffnet ich würde
jetzt in einem hex editor öffnen normalerweise ich weiß nicht wie man das
unter windows macht um ehrlich zu sein wir öffnen die jetzt in notepad nicht
dass es crasht ist zu laut von notepad ok er keine ahnung aber die datei ist
komplett random also man kann nicht darauf schließen also man kann erstens
nicht darauf schließen, was drin ist.
Und man kann auch nicht wirklich
beweisen, dass es ein VeraCrypt-Volume
ist. Ich meine, es ist naheliegend, wenn das so aussieht,
aber es gibt keinen Beweis in dem Sinn,
dass einer sagen könnte, sie haben hier definitiv
ein verschlüsseltes VeraCrypt-Volume.
Nachdem das noch nicht mal
History speichert, kann man noch nicht mal
sehen, dass die Datei das letzte Mal gemountet wurde.
Also ihr könnt das theoretisch abstreiten und sagen,
ey, ich hab keine
VeraCrypt-verschlüsselten Dateien hier drauf.
Und ohne
Passwort geht eh nix.
Also das ist so ziemlich die einfachste Variante, um aus eurer Sicht schützenswerte Dateien unter Windows sicher abzulegen.
Und sobald das Ding wieder unmounted ist, war es das, ist weg.
Wovor euch das Ganze natürlich jetzt weniger schützt ist...
Das sehen die ja. Ja gut, aber die wissen ja immer noch nicht, welche Datei und die haben das Passwort nicht.
Also die Daten sind weg, wenn man die Datei löscht
Logisch
Und die Daten sind weg, wenn man das Passwort vergisst
Solange es kein Easy Passwort ist, was man putforcen kann
Aber dann ist eh die Frage, warum man es so macht
Und sobald das unmounted ist
Ist das Ganze
Nicht mehr lesbar
Wovor es euch nicht schützt ist
Wenn ihr euch
Also teilweise
Wenn ihr euch Malware auf dem Rechner einfangt
dann hat die auch erst mal keinen zugriff auf diese daten daten hier drin so wenn ihr euch
jetzt natürlich aber meldung einfängt mit kilo gar und remote login für angreifer und sowas gut
dann ist es für den natürlich trotzdem relativ easy die steuerung über euren rechner zu übernehmen
und mitzuschneiden welches passwort ihr hier ein tippt also gegen komplett malware verseuchte
Kiste mit Remote Access
wird es euch auf lange Sicht auch nicht schützen.
Wovor es euch allerdings schützt
ist,
solange ihr das Passwort nicht eingibt und wenn
ihr das Passwort nicht gerade im Klartext bei euch
in der Textdatei gespeichert habt,
was man nicht machen sollte,
also das Passwort nicht darauf
in der Textdatei speichern, das war jetzt nur, dass ich
euch das Passwort zeigen kann,
dann kann eine
Malware das jetzt auch nicht auslesen.
Windows macht einfach die No-History-Option kaputt.
Ja.
Tja, Windows.
Remove from list.
Bam.
Aber ist letztendlich auch egal, weil ihr habt das Passwort nicht.
So sieht es aus.
Also das ist tatsächlich die einfachste Variante, Sachen zu schützen unter Windows.
Ohne, dass ihr euch auf irgendwelchen Bitlocker-Shit von Microsoft verlassen müsst.
Wo wir ja gerade gesehen haben, dass das keine allzu gute Idee ist.
Äh.
Okay.
So, hätten wir das auch.
Dann schauen wir uns doch jetzt mal an.
Linux Experience.
Two years later.
Was er dazu zu sagen hat.
16 Minuten.
Gute Länge auch dafür.
I've been playing around with Linux for almost two years now.
und all I've managed to do is set a bunch of people
Microsoft Edge
about how incompetent I am at getting things done
Ja, das ist normal. Man muss ja auch sagen, es gibt ganz viele so Hardcore-Linux-Fanatiker, die der Meinung sind, alle technisch weniger begabten Leute sollen gefälligst kein Linux benutzen und sowas. Das ist natürlich nicht gerade förderlich dafür. Das sind die gleichen Leute, die wahrscheinlich auch im Mikrocontroller-Forum unterwegs sind.
Ja, aber eben angemacht.
Garbage. So a way to fix that
is to give the machine access
to your graphics card. Then you can choose
a better resolution, install and
run games because... Das funktioniert
leider mit VMs unter Windows nicht.
Mit VMs unter Linux
funktioniert das, ich sag mal, potenziell
ähm
hat aber ein paar Falschschräge.
...of all that extra power that it gets.
And that's exactly what I've been trying
to do in my last three videos.
Erst habe ich es manuell gemacht, was mich dazu benötigte, wie man Grub-File,
durch Fahrer durchführen kann, während ich meinen Computer im Prozess komplett zerstöre.
Dann habe ich Ragequit und habe es später wieder versucht.
Diesmal habe ich es tatsächlich geschafft, aber nur einmal.
Ich sage es hat Falschstricke.
Kannst du das Problem erklären? Nee, ich habe mich damit selbst nicht beschäftigt.
Mal gucken, wenn ich das Video gesehen habe.
Restarting my PC, it never worked again
Then in the last video I gave AI
Aber die Browser Passwort Manager brauchen kein Passwort zum Fähr- und Entschlüsseln
Doch, doch, wenn man es richtig macht
Firefox
Not now
Settings
Master Passwort setzen
Das da
Also wenn ihr ein Browser Passwort verwendet
Browser Passwort Manager verwendet in Firefox
Immer das hier einschalten
Use primary password
Dann müsst ihr einmal beim Browser starten, ein Passwort eingeben.
Ne, ich weiß ja nicht, beim Browser starten.
Sobald der Browser auf den Passwortmanager zugreifen will,
müsst ihr ein Masterpasswort eingeben,
dass die Passwörter, die da drin gespeichert werden,
also wenn ihr den Browser Passwortmanager verwendet,
würde ich immer das hier setzen, bei Firefox.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
ob es das nicht um 5 Ecken mittlerweile auch im Chrome gibt,
aber ich glaube nicht.
Ist das Gbait?
Ne, ich meine das ernst.
Ich habe mein ganzes Computer zugeschaltet, um das aufzuhalten.
Und es hat wieder gefehlt.
All I saw at the end was just a bunch of black text on my screen with no way to get back into my operating system.
So I wiped my computer clean and here we are again.
This is now personal.
Hector, this isn't personal.
It is! It is personal!
It's now a matter of principle.
And this time I'm changing my strategy.
Chat?
Chat, ich hab mal ne Frage an euch.
Ähm...
Ich hab jetzt ja über Security-Sachen
auf Twitch und so geredet und euch was
gezeigt. Ich meine, nix Illegales,
ja, vollkommen fein alles.
Aber wie ist das eigentlich?
Darf man sowas
mittlerweile noch zeigen oder verstößt man damit
gegen irgendwelche Dinger?
Also ich sehe jetzt nicht, dass es als
Problem an den Leuten zu zeigen, wie sie ihre Daten
verschlüsseln können, aber man weiß ja echt
mittlerweile nicht mehr, was man darf und was man
nicht darf.
Zeig es raus.
Also ich denke nicht, dass es wirklich ein Problem ist, aber es wird auf YouTube öfters
mal Security Content gelöscht, auch wenn der eigentlich gar nichts Hackerman-mäßiges
zeigt.
Also ich habe jetzt nichts Schlimmes gezeigt.
Es ist vollkommen okay, den Leuten zu zeigen, dass man verschlüsseln darf, aber nicht,
dass irgendein KI-Zusammenfassungs-Algorithmus meint, der Max hat Hacker-Kram im Stream gezeigt.
Genau, genau, bei YouTube weiß ich, ja.
Wollen wir die KI fragen?
Okay, wir fragen, wir fragen, wir fragen die KI.
Wir fragen jetzt, okay, wir fragen, wen fragen wir?
Okay, wir fragen mal, Moment, Duck AI können wir mal fragen.
Was sie dazu sagt.
Duck AI, GPT-5, was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl?
Das können wir, glaube ich, nicht, oder? Das kostet doch Geld.
Heiko45
Captain Fishbone
ich geb deine Nachricht frei
die wurde als
missbräuchliche Nachricht
identifiziert, weil Hackme und sowas
drin vorkam
ok, also fragen wir mal
mal okay wenn man in einem twitch stream den zuschauern zeigt wie man falls unter windows
verschlüsselt hält das dann unter hacken und man wird geflaggt und eventuell gebannt
Ne, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Mal gucken, was das dazu sagt.
Das hängt stark vom
Kontext ab.
Okay.
Grundsätzlich nicht strafbar.
Dass es nicht strafbar ist, ist mir auch klar.
Mir geht es eher darum, dass
irgendwelche Sachen anspringen.
Oh ja, jemand hat
mein neues Emote entdeckt.
Eilverschlüsselung unter Windows zu zeigen, ist
nicht illegal, fällt nicht unter Hacking.
Es ist eine legitime Sicherheitspraxis,
die von Microsoft selbst empfohlen wird.
Aha, Twitch-Richtlinien.
Twitch selbst wird dich wahrscheinlich nicht bannen,
nur weil du zeigst, wie man Dateien verschüsselt.
Das ist normaler Sicherheits-Content,
vergleichbar mit Tutorials zu Passwortmant.
Okay, wann könnte es problematisch sein?
Du zeigst, wie man Ransomware erstellt und nutzt.
Äh, nee.
Du erklärst, wie man fremde Computer hackt und kompromittiert.
Nee.
Der Kontext eindeutig illegal ist.
Mache deutlich, dass es um Datenschutz und Sicherheit geht.
Okay, Leute.
Ich möchte jetzt nochmal betonen, bei allem, was ich heute im Stream hier gezeigt habe, zeige und zeigen werde, geht es nur um Datenschutz und Sicherheit.
Betone, dass das für eigene, private Daten ist.
Genau, ihr dürft keine Daten von anderen Leuten einfach so verschlüsseln.
Es geht nur um eure Daten.
vermeide Begriffe wie verstecken oder vor Behörden verstecken.
Das signalisiert illegale Absicht.
Okay, da habe ich schon mal gelitten,
weil ich gesagt habe, wenn ihr die falschen Leute auf Twitter beleidigt,
kommt ja mittlerweile die Polizei schon zu euch ins Haus.
Zeige vertrauenswürdige Tools.
Okay, ist Veracrypt vertrauenswürdig?
VeraCrypt ist sehr vertrauenswürdig.
Ja, siehste Leute, dann ist doch alles kein Problem.
Also, versteckt nicht eure Sachen,
falls ihr die falschen Leute Pimmel genannt habt oder sowas auf Twitter.
Das ist schlecht.
Nicht, das solltet ihr nicht machen.
Nur Datenschutz und Sicherheit, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich sehe auch nicht...
Das war jetzt nur so halb ernst gemeint mit
Ist das für Probleme? Aber in der heutigen Zeit,
wenn schon das Benutzen von
PHP My Admin
Hacking ist, dann weiß man
in der heutigen Zeit nicht so genau, oder?
Ja, ja.
BAP, my admin hacking
Pass mal auf
Äh, ne
Wie hießen die nochmal?
Äh, Internet?
Ne, ähm, ähm
Oh, ich hab vergessen, wie hießen diese Dinger
Und diese Firma nochmal, die jetzt pleite sind
Äh, Internet?
Irgendwas?
Ihr wisst, was ich meine, ich hab da sogar ein Video zu gemacht
Das hier.
Hallo Leute.
Modern Solutions.
Ja.
Da hat sich einer, also um es mal kurz zusammenzufassen, wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe, also Disclaimer, vielleicht erinnere ich mich dabei kleinen Details nicht mehr richtig.
Modern Solutions hatte eine Datenbank
ungeschützt im Internet hängen
rausbekommen
na ungeschützt stimmt nicht so ganz
Modern Solutions
hatte
eine
Datenbank frei zugänglich
im Internet hängen, das heißt nicht, dass sie nicht geschützt war
wo davon laggt?
ja?
ne, du laggst
ich gebe keine frames
also oder so lustig zahlende festplatte ich muss ich muss mein geduld an machen
das kann ich mir konzentrieren modern solutions hatte eine fest eine
datenbank meine güte und geschützt im internet das heißt man konnte jetzt
darauf zugreifen von also quasi aus dem internet die war aber passwort geschützt
Das Problem war nur, das Passwort für diese Datenbank konnte man, indem man die Anwendung von denen in einem Texteditor geöffnet hat, einfach auslesen.
Und dann hat ein ganz schlimmer Hackerman, zumindest laut dem Gericht, dieses Passwort aus einem Texteditor kopiert, phpMyAdmin gestartet und sich zur Datenbank verbunden.
Und das ist laut deutschem Gericht ein Hacking-Versuch gewesen.
Äh, doch, doch.
Der ist sogar manchmal hier im Stream.
Ich hab...
Er hat sogar mal drüber berichtet im Stream,
wie das Ganze jetzt ausgegangen ist.
Ähm...
Ich hab vergessen, was der letzte Stand war.
Ich habe vergessen, was der letzte Stand war.
Das ging ja dann nochmal vor Gericht.
Video, dazu müsste ich erstmal Videos machen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das Ganze ausgegangen ist.
Zumindest Modern Solution selbst.
Berufungsgericht bestätigt.
Das ist so affig in Deutschland.
Mittlerweile ist es so, Modern Solutions ist anscheinend pleite.
Tja.
Ja, ne? Tja.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir aber mal hier weiter.
Sonst wird das nie was.
Weil ich etwas durch alle meine Linux-Videos erhielt habe.
Geld.
Sie sehen, ihr braucht tatsächlich zwei Grafikkarten, um dieses Setup zu funktionieren.
Einer für den Hauptcomputer und der andere für die Virtual Machine.
karte irgendwie sich sich die initialisieren kann bevor sie zur vm
attached wird oder so was gibt ganz viele dinger aber am besten ist die
grafikkarte die man für die vor allem verwenden will blacklisten dass damit
das haus system linux die erst mal gar nichts macht so in stadt auf trying to
give the virtual machine mein main graphics card und dann was ist aber auch
mittlerweile gibt ist
das dürfte ein Enterprise
Feature sein, ich weiß es nicht,
hab ich nur gelesen,
was es auch gibt, ist die Möglichkeit, wenn man zwei
Grafikkarten hat und
das Fenster aus der
VM trotzdem
bei sich quasi auf dem Desktop
darstellen will von der ersten Grafikkarte,
da gibt es hier Looking Glass
für,
das ist ein
ein Low Latency
KVM FR,
Frame Relay, was auch immer, da kannst du
quasi Sachen aus der VM
rüber kopieren auf
die Hauptgrafikkarte und
dir das da darstellen lassen. Also unter
Linux gibt es ganz abgedrehte Dinger
und coole Sachen.
Weil ansonsten
hast du ja das Problem,
Moment, was?
geht Host die
GPU, iGPU nutzen, damit die
VM-Literatur, ja, ja, ja, das geht.
Das geht.
Ja, weil ansonsten hast du ja das Problem,
dass du die
Grafikkarte halt
auch wirklich wie eine echte
Grafikkarte in einem eigenen Rechner
verwenden musst. Also sprich, du musst
den Monitor an deinem Host anschließen und
du musst einen extra Monitor anschließen an deiner
VM, weil das ist ja eine Grafikkarte
Pass, Pass, Fruit.
Ja.
Was dann teilweise vom Handling her vielleicht ein bisschen eklig sein kann.
Mini-Grafikkarte ist das.
Grafikkarten-Chan.
Gpu-Chan ist das.
Max, wie sieht deiner aus?
Mein PC hat so gut wie keinen Staub, weil, ähm, Staubfilter.
I closed that side back up, then unscrewed this metal thing and lowered this little blip on the connector, as well as slid my graphics card in.
When screwing it in, I lost the screw.
Oh, das ist immer, oh ja, das ist echt zack, wenn du da eine Schraube drin verlierst.
Deswegen mache ich das alles nur noch mit meinem
ultramagnetischen, also das hat nicht
einfach nur einen laschen Magnet,
das hat einen richtig heftigen Magnet
vorne dran.
PB Swiss Schraubendreher.
Das Ding ist wirklich,
also man,
ich lasse mal kurz den Bit
in den Schraubendreher gerade mal reinflutschen,
also man hört es allein schon an der Lautstärke von dem Bit,
habt ihr es gehört, wie der da reinflutscht,
dass das ordentlich zieht,
der Magnet, ja.
Nicht einfach nur so ein bisschen lasch, sondern der ist wirklich ordentlich. Da fällt mir nichts mehr runter. Moin Max, ich habe mal eine Frage. Ich komme vom Bund und habe dort erst IT-Systemelektroniker gelernt, dann IT-Systemadministrator Lehrgang gehabt, habe aber nicht viel damit zu tun gehabt. Jetzt geht es wieder ins zivile Leben. Meine Frage wäre, wovon ich mehr habe, Studium Informatik oder Zertifikate?
ich persönlich halte von Zertifikaten
relativ wenig.
Wenn du Berufserfahrung
hast,
ist halt die Frage, ob du nicht
auch so einen Job irgendwo kriegst.
Das kann ich ehrlich gesagt saumäßig schlecht
einschätzen bei dieser
Kombination.
Also ich persönlich
halte von Zertifikaten nichts
und es ist bei einem Informatikstudium
jetzt auch nicht so, dass du die Leute direkt danach
hinsetzen kannst und sagen, macht.
Ja, die haben zwar einiges an theoretisches
Wissen dazu,
inwieweit das jetzt
in einem praktischen Job tagtäglich
was bringt, hängt
mehr vom Job ab.
Ich kann das
nicht einschätzen. Ich persönlich bin überhaupt kein Fan
von Zertifikaten. Aber wenn du da schon
einige Jahre Berufserfahrung hast,
gibt doch bestimmt
irgendwelche Jobs, wo sich gut
dafür eignen. Ich weiß jetzt
ja nicht, was du hauptsächlich gemacht hast dort,
woran liegt das, dass du kein Fan davon bist?
Weil Zertifikate, also dieses ganze Zertifikat-Ökosystem,
sich für mich immer so darstellt,
als ist das so ein selbsterhaltendes,
sich selbst gegenseitig zuschiebendes Ökosystem.
Also sprich, es gibt Zertifikate, die musst du regelmäßig erneuern.
Es gibt Trainerkurse, es gibt Trainerzertifikate.
Das ist so ein, wir drucken uns, genau, wir drucken uns Geld-System.
Und ich persönlich habe es jetzt auch noch nicht erlebt, dass extrem auf Zertifikate geachtet wurde.
Ja gut, wenn das nicht so viel ist
Ich meine, du könntest auch immer noch eine Physiausbildung machen
Wenn dir das lieber ist
Studium ist halt, also gerade Informatikstudium
Auch wenn man ein bisschen älter ist
Ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ohne
Also ist halt die Frage, ob du
Da noch
Zeit, Lust und Energie für hast
Dich mit sehr viel theoretischem Kram auseinanderzusetzen
Ja
Aber wenn du, sag mal so, wenn du Bock da drauf hast, dann ist das wahrscheinlich das Bessere.
Aber wenn du schon Erfahrung hast, mit ein paar Zertifikaten vielleicht auch nicht vergehen.
Ich, wie gesagt, ich bin, ich halte das ganze Zertifikatszeug echt für, für Geldmacherei.
Also wirklich was raten kann ich dir da nicht so wirklich was.
Weil das Ding ist, der Bund bezahlt mit drei Jahren Fortbildung mit einem finanziellen Rahmen von ca. 13.000 Euro und ich weiß nicht, was der...
Ach so!
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich finde das ja schon mal gut, dass sie prinzipiell gucken, dass ihre Leute dann wieder auch gut ins normale Leben wieder rüber wechseln können.
Das ist ja schon mal nice.
keine Ahnung, ob das was für dich ist,
Informatikstudium. Ich selbst
habe ja keine Informatik studiert.
Chat,
weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht.
Informatikstudium ist halt
sehr viel theoretisch. Das heißt
nicht, dass du danach in eine Firma gehen kannst
und direkt
loslegen.
Ja, also bei uns
sind Studenten während dem Studium eher sowas
wie Praktikanten.
wofür sie eingesetzt werden und auch danach müssen die erstmal eine ganze
weile noch erfahrung und praxis wissen aufbauen
ich kann dir wirklich jetzt nichts großartig zu raten
Wenn du doch Systemelektroniker bist, vielleicht ist was in der Richtung, wenn du da mehr Erfahrung hast, sogar vielleicht eher was.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung, was ich dazu sage.
Also egal, was ich dir sage, wäre jetzt einfach nur geraten.
Du hast Elektro-Technik, okay.
keine ahnung aber ich finde es gut dass sie so was machen sondern sondern sondern über über
übergangsphase programm
ja finde ich gar nicht so schlecht ich gut dass es gibt
ok kommen wir weiter
Er hat sich eine Grafikkarte eingebaut.
Ich habe gerade gedacht, er hat YubiKey etwas cringe ausgesprochen, aber nein, er meint wirklich sowas.
random surprise roaming charges
because it's the only app that's
rechargeable even without a wifi
connection. So what I just do is just
chat, lass mal kurz was überlegen.
200 destinations.
Wir hatten es doch vorhin von
WTF? Wir hatten es doch vorhin
von verschlüsselten Notebooks
und
wo man besser nicht hinfahren sollte
wenn man nicht
zur Herausgabe seines Passworts
überredet werden
soll, ja. Lass mal gucken.
Lass doch mal gucken.
Also,
ähm,
hier willst du schon mal nicht hin.
Hier, so in die Ecke, willst du
wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Australien
ist wahrscheinlich noch okay.
Hier willst du wahrscheinlich auch nirgendswohin.
Nahe Osten willst du wahrscheinlich auch nirgendswohin.
So, Europa geht wahrscheinlich zum
größten Teil noch klar, inklusive England,
Skandinavien. Äh, Südamerika
willst du wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil auch nicht hin?
USA
willst du wahrscheinlich auch nicht hin?
Ja gut,
es gibt nicht so viele Stellen, wo
du da mit deinem Notebook hinfahren solltest.
Stimmt, in den USA, die haben eh schon
alles abgegriffen.
Wobei, ich glaube, genau, Südamerika ist
wahrscheinlich teilweise auch nicht so wild.
Aber hier willst du eher nicht hin.
Hier auch nicht.
In den USA kommt es wahrscheinlich drauf an.
Australien geht, glaube ich, auch gut klar.
Europa geht zum...
Skandinavien, England geht zum Krustenheim bestimmt auch gut klar.
Mit Bitlocker ist es jetzt eh egal.
Da können die es ja direkt entschlüsseln.
Das ist schon kacke, ne?
... und random surprise roaming charges.
Because it's the only app that's rechargeable even without a Wi-Fi connection.
So what I just do is just keep the app always downloaded on my phone.
And if I'm already abroad...
Okay, wir kommen uns das Video an, also gucken wir uns auch mal seinen Sellout an.
... for internet, I just open the app and I can set it up there and then
without having to search for a shady Wi-Fi connection.
Ein E-SIM zu verwandeln, um zu schwappen und zu riskieren,
sich oder physische SIM-Karten zu verlieren, ist einfach...
Ist das nicht so, dass Apple geplant hatte oder hat,
das habe ich auf irgendeiner News-Seite gelesen,
dass eines der neuen, jetzt erscheinenden iPhones
gar keinen physischen SIM-Karten-Slot mehr haben soll?
Da war doch irgendwas.
So quasi E-SIM-only.
... so ein Leben-Upgrade, wenn man reist.
Und UBG macht es super einfach, es aufzusetzen.
Also klickt auf den ersten Link in der Beschreibung und benutzt meinen Komponenten, um einen 10%-Discount auf UBG-Datapläne zu bekommen.
Okay, lasst uns zurückkommen, um die neue Grafikkarte auszutesten.
Jetzt war es Zeit, um zu schauen, ob die neue Grafikkarte funktioniert.
Ich habe sie in meinen Monitor gelegt, habe meinen PC aufgeteilt und habe gesehen, dass es funktioniert.
Um es einfach zu überprüfen, ging ich in die Windows-Settings und sicherlich war es, dass mein PC die neue Grafikkarte benutzt hat.
Wie gut ist die?
Ich kenne mich bei Grafikkarten null aus.
Ich kenne mich nur noch bei Nvidia-Bezeichnungen
halbwegs aus. Wie gut ist denn
eine RX 6400?
Ist das eher
Ultra-Low-End, Low-End-Mittel?
Schnell?
Weiß das jemand?
Würde mich jetzt einfach nur mal interessieren. Hat für das Video keine
Relevanz so wirklich.
Low-End.
Okay.
Ist die?
Okay, okay.
Ist die besser?
Als meine 780M.
Wir gucken einfach mal.
Versus 6400.
Okay, die ist ähnlich kacke.
Die ist ähnlich kacke.
Die sind ziemlich gleich kacke.
54 vs 53.
Okay.
Die sind ziemlich genau gleich scheiße.
Die Grafiker.
Gut.
F für die Partition.
Na, Arch by the way.
Okay, CacheOS ist auch okay.
Okay, auch okay.
Also für so Bastelsachen, glaube ich, ist NixOS echt nicht das Beste, oder?
war cash nicht art space doch computer arch by the way cook
arch by the way wobei steht das steht glaube ich hier gar nicht dabei dass es
art space ist warum steht da nicht cash usx 86 64 arch by the way ich würde
sagen wir sollten neofat unbedingt patchen dass das dabei steht weil weil
wie können wir uns sonst möglichst oft und laut als Arch-Linux-User outen?
Okay, wir machen das anders.
Wartet mal.
Moment.
Okay.
Ah, Moment. Jetzt ist die...
Color? Gibt es sowas wie Color?
Color?
Ich will, dass es Color mit ausgibt.
Ähm.
Wie kann man Neo Fetch...
Wie kann man Neofetch dazu überreden?
Es gibt kein Neofetch.
Immer Color auszugeben?
Gar nicht, oder?
Ah, Fastfetch.
Fastfetch ist es ja. Sorry.
Fastfetch.
Fast Fetch
Print Color
Even When Pipe
Pipe Falls
Mal gucken, ob das funzt
Was funzt?
Bam
CashUS
Arch, by the way
So ist das gut
So, direkt
Function
Neo Fetch
Ups, vielleicht jetzt noch ordentlich
So
Fast Fetch
Wenn man es so richtig schreiben kann
Pipe Falls. Und das können wir rausmachen.
Okay.
Zack.
Und schon kriegen wir auch
immer berichtet, dass es
ein 8-Schlienux ist.
Priorisiert die Shell-Funktion über Alias?
Ich glaube, es gilt das, was zuletzt
definiert wurde. Oder was
zuerst definiert wurde. Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Aber ich hab's ja extra rausgelöscht.
Ich hab ja extra
den alias rausgelöscht. Gut. Wisst ihr? Wichtigsten Sachen direkt erledigt.
Ich glaube, was als letztes in der Config definiert wurde. Ich bin mir aber ehrlich
gesagt nicht sicher.
Flash vom File und hatte hatte Belina
Etcher nicht auch letztens so ein
kleinen Mini?
Ja, kann man nicht Skandal nennen,
aber gab es nicht mal irgendwie
Leute, die vor einem Jahr oder
halbem Jahr gesagt haben, man soll
das nicht mehr verwenden, weil die
da eventuell irgendwelche Sachen
drin haben, die man nicht haben
will.
Da war doch irgendwas.
Aber ich bin eh, was das angeht,
sehr minimalistisch unterwegs.
Nach Möglichkeiten, die ich einfach
auf den USB-Stick drauf.
Etcher habe ich auch in letzter Zeit
mal verwendet. Oder
was ich persönlich richtig gut finde,
aber das geht nur für Raspberry Pi,
ist den
hier.
Der hier ist echt gut. Also nur für
Raspberry Pis.
Wenn ihr mal eine SD-Karte für Raspberry Pi
machen wollt, dann
ist das Ding hier echt praktisch.
der Raspberry Pi Imager
könnt ihr sagen, was habt ihr denn?
Pi 4, Next, OS
64 Bit
by the way, ihr wollt wahrscheinlich nicht das hier
sondern ihr wollt wahrscheinlich
Others und Light
weil das kein Desktop Environment hat
dann könnt ihr sagen, hier
Storage
ich habe jetzt keinen USB Stick
drin und dann kann man noch weitere Sachen einstellen
also den finde ich echt gut, den benutze ich gerne
den Raspberry Pi Imager
Ich konnte mir vorstellen, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Auf dem USB-Stick war wahrscheinlich noch irgendeine Windows-Partition drauf.
Irgendwas, irgendwas Kleines, wo Windows der Meinung war, ich erkenne diesen USB-Stick jetzt,
Hat den USB-Stick quasi gelockt und deswegen konnte Edger nicht weitermachen.
Mit DD hättest du das Problem nicht gehabt. Einfach DD nach DEV, SDC oder was auch immer es ist und Ruhe ist.
Okay, ich habe einen neuen Croissant bekommen.
Schau dir das an, wie lecker das aussieht.
Und den neuen Flashdrive auch.
Ich habe einen neuen USB bekommen und die ganze Prozedur wiedergearbeitet.
Jetzt, dass der USB bereit war, habe ich meinen Computer wiedergearbeitet,
während ich den Delete-Key auf meinem Keyboard schmackte.
Ah, schöne Tastatur hat er da.
Für mich wäre die allerdings nix, weil die kein Num-Block hat.
Und ich mag keine Tastaturen ohne Num-Block.
um in die BIOS-Settings zu kommen.
Alles, was ich von hier aus tun musste, war,
meine USB-Kamera im Boot Priority Menü zu finden,
mit der ich...
In jedem tut es das.
Ich mache das übrigens mittlerweile ganz anders.
Wenn ich einen USB-Stick flashen will, dann mache ich das einfach über meine Linux-Kiste.
Also entweder über meinen Linux-Mini-PC oder meine Linux-VM.
Linux-VM ist auch easy. Einfach den USB-Stick durchreichen und dann dedehen.
was übrigens auch gut, was auch ziemlich gut ist, anstelle, ich habe hier alles nichts drauf, nichts drauf inszeniert,
wer keinen Bock auf Etcher hat, der kann als Etcher-Alternative, also wenn er sagt, ich meine letztendlich Etcher ist irgendeine JavaScript-Anwendung,
wer sagt, der will das nicht, der kann auch, oh, ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt, Image, irgendwas mit Image, ähm,
USB-Imager.
USB-Imager verwenden.
Oh, das gibt es gar nicht als
als Package.
Dann würde ich es nicht unbedingt installieren.
Hast du nichts auf CacheOS?
Äh, nee, habe ich nicht.
Könnte ich aber installieren,
weil das ein richtig guter, zusätzlicher
Package-Manager ist, ja.
Na gut.
Egal, weiter.
Das scheint Alias zu priorisieren.
Aha, siehste.
Auch wenn das...
Hast du mal umgedreht?
Zuerst die Funktion, dann den Alias?
Und umgedreht?
Okay, dann ist das anscheinend so, ja.
Fedora!
Das ist, glaube ich, die deutscheste Aussprache
davon die geht oder
fedora
ok
warum braucht er denn standardmäßigen vpn
ah bestimmt zum linux distribution über torrent runterladen
open code mega nice habe ich auch am start
und jede Menge kostenlose Models dabei
für umsonst, ja.
Erstmal random Sachen vom Internet nach Bash pipen.
Warum nicht?
Ich muss aber dazu sagen, ne,
ich sag ja immer, man sollte es nicht machen,
aber ich mach's auch regelmäßig.
Das ist nicht mein Computer.
Und hilft mir, alles zu setzen, was ich brauche, ohne mich zu verletzen.
Ich mache es manuell.
Okay, es ist installiert, also mache ich Open Code.
Kommand nicht gefunden.
Warte, was?
Open Code.
Da sollte man seine Shell neu starten oder so.
Da geht es bestimmt.
Bestimmt nicht im Path drin.
Ich schalte erst mal auf, öffne ihn wieder und öffne den Code.
Okay, Boom, da sind wir.
Also, im Grunde genommen, hier spreche ich sozusagen mit einem A.I.-Agent.
Welcher OS bin ich?
Big Pickle ist im Open Code immer ein anderes Model, was sie gerade testen wollen.
Ich glaube, aktuell ist es, wie heißt das China Model?
Z-AI? Ne, ähm...
Wartet mal...
GLM!
Aktuell ist es glaube ich GLM, das neueste GLM.
GLM 5.1 oder so, ist glaube ich gerade kostenlos bei OpenCode.
und es sollte das nach ein paar Sekunden wissen.
Fedora Linux 43.
Okay, also es kennt all das.
Jetzt werde ich es fragen.
denn search engines blocken dich halt nach automatisierten suchanfragen das heißt du
bräuchtest dann noch ein wenn ich da lange nichts mitgemacht habe vergesse ich das immer mcp brauchst
du dann auch für suchanfragen sensual ist windows virtual machine for me because it requires like
a bunch of steps as you can tell them a big fan of the mouse cursor getting bigger ja das ist ein
Ein sehr nices Feature, das gefällt mir auch.
Guck hier.
Und vor allem, der wird immer fetter, Leute.
Gatschi Bass.
Was mich allerdings echt irritiert hat bei KDE ist,
guck mal, KDE benutzt keine Vektorgrafiken für den Mauszeiger.
Seht ihr das?
Es ist richtig pixelig.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, KDE benutzt Vektorgrafiken,
aber nein, machen sie nicht.
Es ist immer noch Pixel.
Wie ist das feststellbar, wenn die KI das zum Beispiel mit Curl macht?
Gar nicht.
Die erkenne ich, dass es eine KI ist.
Aber versuch mal, Google-Anfragen oder Dr. Go-Anfragen oder sowas mit Curl zu machen,
indem du das 20 Mal pro Sekunde spammst.
Dann wird es dich auch blocken.
Guck mal, jetzt ist der Mauszeiger so fett, dass er nicht mal mehr in den Bildschirm passt.
Oh.
Oh, das würde mir immer so
auf den Sack gehen, diese Animation, ey.
Die sieht schon cool aus, aber das wäre nervig.
Ich hab eh bei mir hier
alle animationen abgeschaltet guck hier wird nichts mehr animiert egal was du machst okay
doch maximal es wird noch animiert anscheinend aber ansonsten soweit alles abgeschaltet
das nicht eine apple animation doch das ist ein mädchen okay back to this so
now ideally i wanted to set up everything for me so just give it a bunch of instructions
for what to do i need pseudo privileges to install packages and configure the system
was your password
Ich würde jetzt der KI nicht unbedingt ich war mit dem jetzt wirklich zu gucken wie der KI durchklickt ich mich
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob er das auf die Reihe kriegt fragt doch nicht Open Code
Na gut warum nicht
Ich scroll mal vor.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hab keinen Bock ihm zuzugucken, wie er OpenCode eintippt.
Das ist mir zu blöd.
Und, funktioniert's jetzt?
Ah, jetzt ist er bei GitHub geizgelandet, okay.
Ich werde der AI einen Beleuchtungs-Guide geben, der die Wahrheit erkennt.
Wann gibt es...
Das ganze PC-Kreis...
Hier...
Wir...
...dann gehen.
Ich wechsel den Monitor gerade. Hoffentlich ist es nicht schwarz.
Okay, es ist nicht schwarz!
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, GPU-Path-Through zu machen.
Ich habe gerade mein GPU gefunden.
Das ist unglaublich.
Ich habe das Fahrzeug installiert.
Installation voll.
Jetzt, wenn ich mein PC wieder starte und alles gut ist, dann sind wir gut.
Hier gehen wir.
Es hat wieder gestartet.
Okay, okay.
Ich denke, das ist es.
Ich denke, wir sind gut.
Es gibt ein anderes Display.
Oder so, so geht's natürlich auch.
Okay, let me try to switch.
Boom.
Oh, I see Windows.
Finally.
It was so much easier to...
Was ein Ektor.
...pass through that other GPU.
It worked like immediately.
So my main one is just completely cooked for this.
Now I'm installing something called a looking glass, which will...
Ah, ich hab's euch ja vorher noch gezeigt.
Genau, mit looking glass kannst du das dann rüberspiegeln.
...let me see Windows inside that virtual machine on this screen here...
Fast ohne Delay.
Und Looking Glass?
Kriegen wir jetzt nicht Looking Glass gezeigt?
Ich wusste es, dass sowas kommt.
Ich wusste es, deswegen habe ich schon leiser gemacht.
Naja, das Video jetzt war jetzt nicht so...
Was kriege ich hier eigentlich wieder für Zeug empfohlen, Alter?
Fast Vergiftung, dann Nummer geklärt.
Aha, alles klar.
Portemonnaie beim ersten Date.
Fünf top bezahlte Jobs.
Fuck.
Okay, das wollte ich noch angucken.
Microsoft Edge verrät eure Passwörter.
Das war ja vorher auch schon Thema im Chat.
Verrät eure Passwörter.
Leute, vielleicht habt ihr das schon mitbekommen.
Wenn nicht, solltet ihr es euch mal reinziehen.
Vor allem, wenn ihr auf Windows den Browser Edge benutzt.
Hat Microsoft nicht gesagt,
Das wäre ein Feature?
Hat da Microsoft nicht drauf geantwortet, das ist ein Feature?
Ich bilde mir ein, das habe ich gelesen.
Passwort-Manager von Edge, eure Passwörter speichert.
Okay, Moment, was soll ein Passwort-Manager nochmal machen?
Design-Entscheidung.
Er soll die Passwörter speichern und wenn ihr sie braucht, auf Webseiten ohne Rumgetippe eintragen.
Aber vor allem soll er die Passwörter sicher speichern.
Das bedeutet zum Beispiel, dass die Passwörter erst bei Bedarf entschlüsselt werden und nicht die ganze Zeit im Klartext im Arbeitsspeicher liegen.
Das wäre sinnvoll, ja.
Damit bei einem Cyberangriff dem Angreifer nicht einfach eure komplette Passwortdatenbank sofort auf dem Silbertablett serviert wird.
So, und jetzt ratet mal was Microsoft macht.
Das hat nämlich vor ein paar Tagen der norwegische Sicherheitsforscher Sønstep Seta Rönning rausgefunden und ganz ehrlich...
Alter, das ist ein krasser Name.
Das ist der norwegischste Name, den ich je gesehen habe.
Das Ganze ist so einfach nachzustellen, dass ihr das auch einfach zu Hause nachmachen könnt.
Natürlich nur mit euren eigenen Daten auf eurem eigenen Rechner.
Ich wüsste nicht mal, wie ich die Zeichen überhaupt eintippen soll.
Ich habe hier dafür diese Demo eingerichtet mit ein paar Dummy-Accounts.
Das ist ein Windows 11 mit Edge und in den Passwortmanager eben zwei Testaccounts eingetragen.
Zum Beispiel eins für einen Online-Shop und eins für ein IT-Magazin.
Und das sieht ja erstmal ziemlich sicher aus, oder?
Also wenn ich diese gespeicherten Passwörter jetzt angucken will, muss ich mich per Windows Hello einmal authentifizieren.
In diesem Fall per PIN-Eingabe.
So, und jetzt könnt ihr mal Folgendes machen.
Den Edge öffnen, nichts weitermachen, keine Seiten besuchen.
Dann öffnet ihr den Taskmanager und dann habt ihr hier...
Die Prozess-IDs.
den Microsoft Edge. Das klappt ihr hier so auf und dann klickt ihr mit der rechten Maustaste auf
diesen Hauptprozess hier mit dem Namen Browser und dann auf Speicherbilddatei erstellen. Und jetzt
im Hexeditor öffnen oder wie oder was? Und dann könnt ihr hier klicken auf Datei Speicherort
öffnen. Das Teil liegt dann in so einem Ordner für temporäre Dateien drin, msedge.dmp. Jetzt guckt
ihr in diese Datei rein. Dafür nehmt ihr am besten einen Hexeditor, weil Windows für sowas selber gar
keine praktischen Tools mitliefert. Ein
Hexeditor ist ein Programm, das euch den Inhalt
einer Datei anzeigt und nicht nur
einfach als Text ausgibt, sondern
Byte für Byte im Hexadezimalformat.
Deshalb halt auch Hexeditor.
Ich nehme dafür hier das Tool...
By the way, das zählt jetzt auch schon als Hacking?
XD?
Den habe ich auch schon verwendet.
Kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor, der Name.
Super kleiner Download,
gerade mal 3-4 MB groß.
den habe ich hier schon mal installiert und wenn ihr dann hxt öffnet einfach diese ms edge punkt
dmp dateien wobei so sah er nicht aus aber mir kommt der name bekannt vor und in egal hex hex
dampf beste einfach direkt ziehen aber da kannst du nicht wirklich gescheit editieren trainer in
das fenster reinziehen so also in hex dann wir einfach mal steuerung f und gebt einen suchbegriff
ein dann nehme ich natürlich direkt mal das test passwort von eben und siehe da er findet das auch
Ja, nice. Toll. Sehr gut gemacht, Microsoft.
Schön gevibecoded.
Es kommen etwas häufiger in dieser Datei vor, aber ein Angreifer braucht gar nicht irre viel Geduld, um die Stelle zu finden, an der dann auch das Passwort hinterlegt ist.
Ja, und es wird sogar noch besser, denn es reicht aus, wenn ihr den Edge einmal geöffnet und dann wieder geschlossen habt.
Aha.
Ihr schließt dabei nämlich...
Der läuft im Hintergrund weiter. Ach so.
...läuft Edge trotzdem als Hintergrundprozess weiter.
Auch wenn ihr davon dann ein Abbild macht, liegen da nach wie vor ebenfalls die Passwörter im Klartext drin.
Auch spannend, Edge basiert auf Chromium.
Das ist die Engine, die auch zum Beispiel den Kern von Googles Chrome Browser und noch von ein paar anderen Browsern bildet.
Die hat Svens-Besitter Röning natürlich auch getestet und konnte das Verhalten dort aber nicht nachvollziehen.
Und wir haben das natürlich auch mal ausprobiert mit Chrome.
Gleiches Setting, Passwörter sind nicht auffindbar.
Also wenn ihr euch jetzt mit dem Umstieg auf einen wirklich guten Passwortmanager wie KeyPassXC auseinandersetzt, ist das natürlich eine super coole Idee.
Aber für mehr Passwortsicherheit müsst ihr das gar nicht. Es reicht schon aus, zum Beispiel von Edge auf Chrome umzusteigen.
Wie traurig ist das denn?
Oder Firefox, da könnt ihr sogar ein Masterpasswort setzen.
Und welchen Passwortmanager nutzt ihr eigentlich? Und welchen Browser? Schreibt es doch gerne mal in die Kommentare.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, liked es gerne und folgt uns auch gerne. Danke und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich muss noch was gucken.
Gibt es Edge für Linux?
Fuck.
Es gibt Microsoft Edge für Linux?
Aber warum?
Und warum verwenden das so viele Leute?
Ich werde mir das jetzt nicht installieren zum ausprobieren.
Ich installiere das nicht.
Kein Problem.
Webentwicklung.
Okay, dafür verstehe ich. Das macht sogar Sinn.
Ja, wenn man sagt, man möchte alle Sachen jetzt irgendwie in den größeren Browsern testen.
Okay, ja, ja, lasse ich mir gefallen.
Wobei ich halt denke, die Darstellung zwischen Edge und Chrome sollte sich jetzt nicht so groß unterscheiden.
Aber okay, verstehe ich, verstehe ich.
Ja, wenn man sagt, man möchte das mit unterschiedlichen Browsern testen.
Okay, macht Sinn.
Nun ja
Microsoft macht Microsoft-Dinge
Okay, welches lass hat der hier am Start?
Ich mach das mal ein bisschen schneller jetzt
Basiert Edge auch auf Chrome?
Ja, mittlerweile schon
Früher war das was eigenes
Also sie hatten ja erst Internet Explorer
Und dann hatten sie Edge V1
Edge V1 war quasi
Eine eigene Browser-Engine
Damals
eigenes JavaScript, eigene HTML und CSS-Gedöns.
Wir haben aber festgestellt, dass das Maintainen eines weiteren Browsers
wohl doch nicht so easy ist, wie man sich das gedacht hat
und sind dann auf Chromium-based gewechselt.
Ich skippe nur mal drüber.
Okay, das ist ein NAS ohne Wechselrahmen.
Das wäre schon mal nichts für mich.
Oder? Doch mit Wechselrahmen?
Ah doch, ah doch, okay, okay, okay, doch, doch, doch, doch, wechsel da.
Oder wie viele Einschübe hat der da drin?
Das ist, das ist, das ist komplett over, overrated, äh, overengineered für, für meine Verhältnisse.
So viele, so viele Lüfter.
Gibt's da überhaupt einen ordentlichen, sinnvollen Lüftungsstrom bei so vielen Lüftern?
Und was ist der Stromverbrauch?
Ah, ein Noctua-Lüfter.
Was hat er für ein Mainboard? Das interessiert mich eigentlich.
Der Rest ist mir ziemlich wurscht.
Was hat er für ein Mainboard?
Mainboard, hier.
Ah, Supermikro. Okay.
Naja, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt das, was ich...
Ist es überhaupt...
Okay, ist es halt...
Warum sind manche Videos am Anfang immer so laut?
Was haben wir denn sonst?
Alles klar.
Neu bei Linux.
Diese fünf Windows-Gewohnheiten solltest du ablegen.
Okay, ich rate mal.
Ich rate mal, ja.
Die erste Sache ist,
oder, das ist ja keine Angewohnheit wirklich.
Aber ich würde mal sagen,
das erste ist, dass die Kommandozeile gefährlich ist.
Und scheiße.
Das ist das, was viele Windows-Leute denken.
Und das denken Windows-Leute auch zu Recht,
weil es unter Windows so ist.
aber unter Linux ist das nicht so
das nächste ist, ja, das würde ich auch sagen
genau die gleiche Idee hatte ich auch
Package Manager
ähm
du brauchst keine extra Treiber in der Regel
ist das nächste, brauchst keine Treiber installieren
und ansonsten habe ich keine Ahnung
doch, Windows
ähm
Batch ist scheiße.
Sowohl früher das alte Terminal
war richtig scheiße
und jetzt ist es nur noch Batch scheiße.
Was ganz okay ist für Automatisierung
ist PowerShell.
Aber PowerShell
ist keine gute interaktive Shell.
Achso, Linux Shell ist okay.
Okay, guck mal hier. Software installieren.
Die Angst vorm Terminal
ist genau das, was ich auch gesagt habe.
Also die zwei Sachen hatten wir schon mal.
Leute, Leute
Ich hab das vorher nicht geguckt, ja
Ähm, wo ist das C-Laufwerk?
Okay, das hätte ich jetzt
Ja gut, Ordnerstruktur
Ja, ständig neu starten
Muss man auch nicht, okay, das stimmt
Das stimmt, wobei bei einem
Kernel-Update muss man in der Regel neu starten
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Hab ich jetzt vorher eins rebooted oder nicht?
Und noch viel wichtiger, gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile
Neue Updates? Ich meine, wir haben schon immerhin
drei Stunden nicht geupdatet.
Ah, endlich.
Endlich wieder Bleeding Edge unterwegs.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Ich brauche immer neueste Packages.
Sonst komme ich mir so outdated,
overrated, jebaited vor.
Bin ich die Einzige?
Warum junge Leute keinen Job finden?
Ne, da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Was ist es wert?
Tja, das ist sehr individuell, würde ich sagen.
Gibt es vielleicht noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Hat hier jemand schon mal einen Terminal-Emulator programmiert?
Nee.
Start Microsoft!
Diese vier Office-Pakete, das ist ja genau das Richtige für mich.
Ich benutze keinerlei Office-Pakete.
die kommen garantiert um die Ecke
lass mich mal raten, lass mich raten
die kommen mit
OpenOffice um die Ecke, unter anderem
OpenOffice ist halt
ich mein, es hat nicht
den ganzen Microsoft Shit dabei
was es ja an sich schon mal nicht verkehrt
macht, aber die Bedienung
und generell Office Programme
ich mag keine Office Programme, egal was es ist
vielleicht haben die auch
dieses Euro Office
Ding mittlerweile dabei.
Wir haben undercover
einen Gaming PC. Oh, das klingt
ähm
Vielleicht haben wir auch
Euro Office. Wobei Euro Office, wisst ihr, ich bin der Meinung,
das wird komplette Todgeburt.
Okay, lass mal kurz. Libre Office,
Only Office, Softmaker Office,
WPS Office,
Office
Okay.
Also, müssen wir nicht gucken. Easy.
Das finde ich viel interessanter.
Herzlich willkommen bei Hardware Deals.
Ihr seht, ich stehe nicht in der gewohnten Umgebung.
Ich stehe hier vor dem Mediamarkt.
Denn es ist ja schon eine Weile her, dass wir undercover im Mediamarkt unterwegs waren.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob die immer noch genauso kacke sind wie früher.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, die Antwort ist ja, sind sie.
Was übrigens früher auch immer lustig war, wo sich Saturn und Mediamarkt gegenseitig öffentlich bekriegt haben,
zumindest so getan haben, so nach dem Motto, wir schlagen die im Preis und wir schlagen die im Preis.
Dabei war das der gleiche Laden.
Das ist die gleiche, wie nennt man das?
Firma dahinter, hinter Mediamarkt und Saturn.
Um einen Gaming-PC zu kaufen.
Heute ist es wieder soweit.
Wir werden heute mal schauen, was gibt es aktuell im Mediamarkt für Gaming-PCs.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall schon ziemlich gespannt, wie die Beratung ausfallen wird.
Aber ich möchte natürlich nicht erkannt werden.
Deswegen muss ich hier meine Tarnkappe anziehen.
Und ich glaube, wir bauen jetzt hier alles um auf unser Undercover-Setup und dann gehen wir rein in den Markt.
Erstmal eine Runde Sellout.
Du wachst auf und fühlst dich, als hättest du gar nicht geschlafen.
Dann liegt es oft nicht an dir, sondern an deiner Matratze.
Für ein besseres Schlaferlebnis gibt es von Emma genau das Richtige für euch.
Die neue Emma Performance Matratze im Vergleich zu normalen Matratzen deutlich luxuriöser und komfortabler.
Gibt es in verschiedenen Größen und drei Höhen.
Spannend ist vor allem die Deepcorn Komforttechnologie.
Also ich habe seit 2013 die gleiche Matratze vom Ikea und die Pfunz einfach.
So advanced wie die hier ist die natürlich nicht.
Dass die hier irgendwelche extra Stoßdämpfer hätte.
Körper an und fängt Bewegung direkt ab.
Dazu kommt die Airgrid Struktur, ein flexibles Gitter, das Druck gleichmäßiger verteilt und das Liegegefühl deutlich ruhiger macht.
Was ich besonders sinnvoll finde, der Bezug ist abnehmbar und waschbar und du kannst die Matratze bis zu 100 Nächte risikofrei testen.
Wenn du auch ein Upgrade für deinen Schlaf haben möchtest, dann schau gerne bei der neuen Emma Performance Linie vorbei.
Und das Beste, aktuell kannst du beim Comfort Sale auf viele Produkte bis zu 50% sparen.
Und mit dem Code HARDWEAR gibt es nochmal 5% on top.
Den Link dazu findet ihr wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung.
So, da bin ich ja jetzt schon mal gespannt, was wir hier heute finden werden.
Hier gibt es jetzt einen Gaming-PC für Gaming geeignet.
Und das ist ja hier wie im Baumarkt.
Hier gibt es einfach keine Mitarbeiter.
Ich würde mich ja eigentlich gerne beraten.
Also, wie zu erwarten, dass sie sich wieder verstecken.
Lassen, aber hier ist niemand.
Dann müssen wir gleich mal auf die Suche gehen.
Ein paar Sekunden später.
Hi, kennst du dich auch mit den Gaming-PCs aus?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich suche was so um die 1000 Euro.
Hm, okay.
Für Fortnite oder so Story-Spiele wie Cyberpunk oder ähnliches, welchen könntest du mir da denn empfehlen?
PC oder Laptop?
Äh, PC.
Okay, da muss ich mal kurz schauen. Für 1000 Euro?
Ja, genau.
Okay, die hier sind ausgestellt, muss ich kurz schauen. Also um die 1000 Euro haben wir eigentlich nur den hier.
Okay, und da ist das hier drin verbaut.
Einen ganzen.
Oder?
Die Sachen, die da stehen, ja genau. Und die sollten eigentlich auch ausreichend sein für die ganzen Story-Spiele oder Fortnite oder so.
Okay, dann aber auch in Full-HD, oder?
Genau, ja.
Da ist ne 5060 drin, oder?
Mhm.
Dann würde ich den, glaube ich, ausprobieren.
Alles klar, PC kannst du vorne an der Kasse abholen.
Okay, danke dir, ciao.
Bitte schön, ciao.
Geile Beratung.
Also die waren nicht wirklich vorhanden, oder?
Und ist eine 5060 nicht ziemlich low-end?
Oder nein, vielleicht nicht lowest-end, aber, aber, was haben wir so in...
Vielleicht low zu ganz knapp mittel?
Oder was ist
Was ist ne 5090
Ja dass das für Fortnite reicht ist klar
Aber was ist ne 50
Was ist ne 5060
Okay
Ist das ne Mittelklasse oder ne Low
Low Karte
Low
Okay
Also bin ich
Massive
Overrated
Cheapated mit meiner 4090
Für 1080p oder
Aber das wusste ich vorher auch schon
Aber dafür kann ich alles mit 500 FPS
Spielen
Ich habe den Gaming-PC, war auf jeden Fall eine etwas kürzere Beratung.
Ja, kann man so sagen.
Er hat gesagt, ich kann damit Story-Spiele und...
Zockst du auf 1080? Ja, 1080 mit 240 Hertz.
In Full-HD-Auflösung auf jeden Fall zocken und das werden wir gleich herausfinden.
Und wir werden natürlich auch schauen, was hier so drin verbaut ist, wie dieser PC aufgebaut ist.
Das ist ja sogar der Mediamarkt-eigene Gaming-PC.
Ich glaube, da lohnt es sich sowieso, den mal anzuschauen.
Wir sind zurück mit unserer Ausbeute, zurück im Studio und wir haben den Media Markt Gaming PC dabei.
Ihr habt es gesehen, ich habe mich gerade beraten lassen.
Die Beratung war ein bisschen kurz.
Die Beratung ist so, naja, ich sage mal kurz ausgefallen.
Kannst du mir helfen?
Ich kann dir nicht helfen.
Ich habe einfach nach einem 1000 Euro Gaming PC gesucht und dann wurde mir eigentlich nur dieser hier empfohlen.
Der hat jetzt auch 1400 Euro gekostet, also sogar 400 Euro über meiner Preisvorstellung.
Ich kann euch sagen, warum ich noch auf 1080p bin.
Weil zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich mir den Monitor gekauft habe, gab es die 240 Hertz Monitore nur in 1080p.
So.
Mittlerweile würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch was anderes kaufen.
Der Verkäufer meinte auch nur in der Preisklasse, gibt es eigentlich nur dieses Gerät hier.
Der ist schon mal schön RGB und bunt.
Mit dem ich Fortnite spielen kann, mit dem ich Story Games spielen kann, in Full HD Auflösung.
Die weiteren Settings habe ich jetzt nicht mit ihm besprochen.
Ich habe auch gar nicht so genau drauf geachtet, was wir hier drin verbaut haben.
Moment, das war es jetzt?
Mehr Media Markt kommt da nicht?
Alter, das waren 30 Sekunden.
Ich habe gedacht, da kommt jetzt noch irgendwie was, wo sich Media Markt voll, voll irgendwie den Fail geleistet hat oder so.
Der Rest ist einfach nur noch angucken von dem PC.
Okay, das ist guter Titel, guter Titel, würde ich sagen.
Hat gebated.
In meiner letzten Home-Line-Bildung
Was für ein Video.
Oh, Chat, ich sehe gerade, die Mikrowelle ist an.
Ihr wisst, was das bedeutet.
Jetzt gibt's Futter.
Peppo Fett Time.
Vier Stunden Stream.
Fast vier Stunden Stream.
Das reicht.
Vielleicht nachher noch eine Runde mal gucken.
Wir hören uns.
Wenn euch der Stream gefallen hat und noch nicht gefollowt hat,
kann mir gerne ein Foto da lassen.
Ich bin immer Sonntagmorgens da und unter der Woche auch unregelmäßig, random, wenn es gerade passt.
Wochenende potenziell öfters als unter der Woche.
Bastelstream.
Bastelstream wäre echt mal wieder nice, ja.
Finde ich auch, hast du schon recht.
Bastelstream wäre sehr pog.
So, wir hören uns, Leute.
Bis denn.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
See you.